Aujourd'hui, on va vous parler du sujet préféré des Français quand
il s'agit de débattre de l'énergie, c'est-à-dire du nucléaire.
Comme vous le savez, quand on fait avec les atomes,
on peut "obtenir" ou faire interagir un atome avec de l'énergie.
Il y a deux manières distinctes d'ab]voir
de l'énergie impliquée dans quelque chose qui se passe au niveau d'un atome.
Vous pouvez soit avoir un réarrangement des couches d'électroniques
et à ce moment ça s'appelle soit une excitation, soit une réaction chimique.
Ou vous pouvez avoir un réarrangement des nucléons ; et à ce moment ça s'appelle une énergie nucléaire.
L'énergie nucléaire, c'est l'énergie du réarrangement des nucléons
que vous pouvez avoir avec des noyaux atomiques.
Il ya deux manières d'obtenir –ou plus exactement d'avoir – de l'énergie nucléaire.
La première c'est l'énergie qui est associée à la fission.
Dans la fission, on prend un gros noyau, on le casse deux gros morceaux
et en plein d'autres petits
et ça c'est une réaction qui libèrent de l'énergie.
Et la deuxième manière,
c'est au contraire de prendre des noyaux très légers et de les fusionner.
Et à ce moment, c'est pareil, vous avez de l'énergie qui est disponible.
En gros. dans les deux cas de figure, on profite du fait que l'énergie de liaison dans  dans les noyaux
n'est pas la même, quelle que soit la taille du noyau,
est donc dans les petits et les très gros noyau
l'énergie de liaison est un peu plus faible que dans les noyaux intermédiaires.
Et donc, en réarrangeant la taille des noyaux, vous pouvez obtenir de l'énergie.
Ou bien vous faites de la fission
la fission, ça consiste à faire cette réaction la: casser un noyau en deux avec libération d'énergie.
Cette énergie, comme on va le voir, elle est essentiellement contenue
soit dans du rayonnement électromagnétique,
soit dans l'énergie cinétique des bouts de noyaux
(donc des petits noyaux après fission)
Ou bien, on fait l'exact inverse, on fait de la fusion,
C'est-à-dire qu'on assemble – on joue au Légo –
et à ce moment le différentiel de d'énergie de liaisons
se retrouve également libéré dans l'environnement
sous forme (également) d'énergie cinétique et de rayonnement électromagnétique.
Quelque chose qui est important, c'est de savoir qu' il y a un énorme facteur multiplicateur
entre l'énergie chimique
(c'est à dire l'énergie du réarrangement des électrons que vous pouvez avoir avec un atome)
et l'énergie nucléaire
(c'est à dire l'énergie du réarrangement des nucléons)
et l'ordre de grandeur entre les deux – qu'il faut garder en tête – est de l'ordre du million.
Dit autrement, vous avez un million de fois plus d'énergie
dans la fission d'un gramme d'uranium que dans la combustion d'un gramme de pétrole.
Je vous le dis encore autrement: fissionner un gramme d'uranium libère
la même quantité d'énergie thermique que de brûler une tonne de pétrole.
La raison à cela, c'est que l'énergie typique de réarrangement d'une couche electronique
c'est quelques électrons-Volt.
L'énergie typique d'une réaction de fission ,ces quelques centaines de millions d'électronvolts
– dont vous perdez une partie au passage mais peu importe.
Donc la raison pour laquelle
l'énergie nucléaire est très concentrée,
c'est lié à ça.
C'est lié au fait que l'énergie de réarrangement des noyaux dans un atome
est quelque chose de beaucoup plus intense
que l'énergie de réarrangement des électrons.
On a, soit dit en passant,
une grosse bombe thermonucléaire permanente dans notre environnement
qui nous rend bien service et qui s'appelle le Soleil.
Le Soleil, c'est un endroit où vous avez de la fusion
en permanence – c'est assez gros.
Ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que, en fait, toutes les énergies
que nous utilisons sur Terre sont des dérivées directes ou indirectes de l'énergie nucléaire
Le rayonnement solaire, à l'évidence, dérivé de l'énergie nucléaire ;
toutes les énergies fossiles sont des énergies dérivées de la photosynthèse
donc indirectement dérivé du rayonnement solaire, donc de l'énergie nucléaire.
etc.
En gros, sans énergie nucléaire,
nous ne sommes pas sur Terre
et toutes les énergies que nous utilisons sont des dérivés plus ou moins
direct de l'énergie nucléaire.
Le vent, c'est pareil, etc.
C'est amusant mais l'énergie nucléaire est à l'origine
encore une fois d'à peu près toutes les sources d'énergie qu'on utilise sur Terre.
Le nucléaire a une particularité
– qui n'en est pas une –
c'est que, comme vous le savez probablement,
il a démarré son existence sur Terre sous forme militaire.
C'est pas tout à fait vrai, parce qu'avent de faire la bombe atomique,
il a fallu faire la pile de Fermi,
qui, soit dit en passant, avait la puissance
totalement ridicule d'un demi watt.
On peut faire des tout petits réacteurs nucléaires, la preuve
c'est que la pile de Fermi faisait 0,5 watt de puissance.
Mais après les premières manifestations visibles ont été des manifestations aux militaires.
Et du coup, c'est une partie de la mauvaise presse qui est liée au nucléaire.
Cela étant, quand vous regardez un peu dans l'histoire des technologies
mises au point par les hommes,
à peu près tout ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui à titre civil est – malheureusement – né
–pas tout mais beaucoup de trucs –
sont nés à cause de velléités militaires.
C'est notamment le cas pour la robotique, par exemple.
C'est le cas pour internet.
C'est le cas pour une bonne partie des engins à moteur, etc.
On a d'abord cherché à en faire des usages militaires avant d'en faire des usages civils.
De ce point de vue, le nucléaire fait pas exception.
Je ne sais pas s'il faut dire heureusement ou malheureusement.
Alors quand on s'intéresse à la production électrique,
le nucléaire, fondamentalement,
c'est une manière de faire bouillir de l'eau.
C'est fondamentalement ça.
Donc, une centrale nucléaire c'est fondamentalement une bouilloire compliquée.
C'est ça que c'est aujourd'hui.
C'est quelque chose qui permet de faire bouillir de l'eau en grande quantité.
Sans utiliser d'oxydation du carbone,
c'est-à-dire sans combustion.
Et, on va le voir
– nonobstant ce qui peut être dit ici et là –
pour pas très cher.
On n'aura pas le temps aujourd'hui de disserter de façon approfondie sur tous ces aspects
– même si j'avais eu l'horaire normal,
malheureusement, je n'aurais pas eu le temps parce que c'est des débats techniques et compliqué –
mais en gros c'est ça l'idée : c'est
une grande quantité d'énergie,
pas de combustion
et pas très très cher.
La différence entre une centrale nucléaire et une centrale à charbon ou une autre centrale thermique,
elle est donc dans la manière de produire la chaleur.
En ce qui concerne une centrale à charbon, ou fait brûler du charbon
En ce qui concerne une centrale nucléaire, vous faites fissionner des atomes.
Tout ce qui se passe derrière est identique.
C'est-à-dire que dans un cas comme dans l'autre, ça va vous dégager des grandes quantités de chaleur.
Avec ces grandes quantités de chaleur, vous allez créer de la vapeur.
Et avec cette vapeur vous allez faire tourner une turbine – un truc avec des ailettes.
Il se passe la même chose que dans l'alternateur de votre voiture, c'est-à-dire qu'une fois que vous avez mis
un rotor en rotation dans un champ magnétique, éh bien, ça vous sort du courant.
Vous pouvez avoir dans les deux cas de figure, ou pas,
ce qu'on appelle un aéroréfrigérant,
cette grande tour que vous voyez.
C'est l'image d'Épinal de la centrale nucléaire à la télévision:
c'est cette grande tour qui fume.
Cette grande tour qui fume n'est rien d'autre qu'une tour de refroidissement.
C'est donc votre source froide de votre machine de Carnot.
Et cette tour de refroidissement,
vous en avez besoin
que vous ayez du nucléaire ou que vous ayez du charbon
dès lors que vous êtes en bord de rivière
et donc que vous avez besoin de la chaleur latente d'évaporation pour refroidir
parce que le débit de la rivière n'est pas suffisant pour refroidir simplement par conduction thermique.
Quand vous êtes en bord de mer,
votre source froide, c'est d'aller perdre des calories dans la mer
et vous n'avez pas besoin d'aero-réfrigérant.
Donc quand vous regardez une centrale nucléaire française qui est située en bord de mer
– Gravelines ou Penly ou Blayais –
vous n'avez pas d'aéro-réfrigérant.
Par contre, quand vous avez une centrale à charbon en bord de rivière,
vous avez une tour de refroidissement comme celle là.
Donc la tour de refroidissement, ce n'est pas l'apanage du nucléaire,
c'est l'apanage de la centrale thermique en bord de rivière.
Le nucléaire est, c'est une manière de produire de l'électricité,
donc c'est quelque chose que vous voyez apparaître dans les énergies finales.
Ici, là, dans l'électricité.
C'est aujourd'hui – je l'ai dit la dernière fois– un peu moins de 15 % d'électricité mondiale.
C'est une part qui a plutôt tendance à baisser un peu,
parce que le nucléaire est plutôt une énergie aujourd'hui qui n'a pas beaucoup cote par rapport à d'autres.
Alors, si je regarde combien on produit d'énergie nucléaire dans le monde
– vous voyez ici la production depuis 1965.
C'est une énergie qui est très récente – encore une fois, la pile de Fermi c'est 1942
donc avant 42, il n'y en avait pas beaucoup.
Vous voyez que c'est quelque chose qui s'est fortement  accéléré
après les chocs pétroliers,
qui a fortement ralenti au moment des contrechocs dans les années 80
qui s'est beaucoup calmé après le début des années 2000
à un moment où, soit dit en passant, le pétrole était pas très cher.
Ici, vous voyez la conséquence, à la fois de la crise de 2009
et de Fukushima.
Et puis depuis, ça recommence à monter gentiment.
On verra que les Japonais redémarrent des réacteurs les uns derrière les autres.
Alors là vous avez une image un peu globale en ce qui concerne le nucléaire.
Après vous pouvez avoir des images qui sont extrêmement
discriminées par par pays
Ici, vous avez l'exemple de l'Italie.
L'Italie, comme vous le voyez, a un réacteur nucléaires en fonctionnement.
La puissance typique d'un réacteur nucléaire, c'est entre un demi gigawatts et un gigawatts.
L'EPR, c'est un très gros réacteur qui fait un gigawatt et demi ; mais c'est entre un demi et un gigawatt.
Est-ce  que vous savez qu'on il y a d'heures dans l'année?
8760.
Donc si vous prenez un gigawatt
et que ça fonctionne à puissance maximale toute l'année, à la fin de l'année,
vous avez bien 8760 GWh.
Et si on traduit ça en térawattheures, ça fait ?
8,7.
Alors comme une centrale nucléaire ça fonctionne pas tout le temps parce que, de temps en temps,
il faut l'arrêter pour recharger, pour et caetera,
pour faire des trucs et des machins,
et puis de temps en temps ça ne fonctionne pas à pleine puissance
[repris]
En France, ça ne fonctionne pas tout à le temps à pleine puissance.
Dans la quasi-totalité des autres pays, si.
En gros, retenez qu'une centrale nucléaire de 1GW, dans l'année, elle va vous produire de 6 à 8 TWh.
Donc ça vous donne une règle simple:
une fois que vous voyez sur les graphiques la quantité de terawattheures produite dans l'année,
Là vous voyez qu'il y 4 TWh d'abord,
8 TWh ensuite,
donc ça ça vous dit que l'Italie avait d'abord un réacteurs d'un gigawatt – ou deux d'un demi gigawatts, je sais pas –
puis ensuite, elle a doublé ça.
C'est ça que ça veut dire.
Oui?
[question inaudible]
Non, une centrale peut avoir plusieurs réacteurs.
En France, c'est 3 ou 4.
La plus grosse, c'est Gravelines qui doit avoir 5 ou 6 – je ne sais plus –
Ça peut descendre à 2.
Mais en général vous en avez plusieurs sur site.
Donc, là, vous voyez l'Italie à un réacteur en fonctionnement.
Elle en met un deuxième en fonctionnement.
Et puis là, qu'est ce qui se passe?
Tchernobyl.
Référendum en Italie.
Décision de sortie du nucléaire.
Et crac, overnight, y'a plus rien.
Ici, vous avez un autre pays bien connu :
c'est le Japon.
Vous voyez le Japon a une production qui augmente
qui est quasi stable – de temps en temps il y a dû y avoir des fermetures –
là, vous avez Fukushima.
Et puis ils ont commencé à en redémarrer
Il en ont redémarré 8 ou 10 – je ne sais plus
Ici vous avez l'Allemagne.
J'ai volontairement masqué les abscisses – il n'y a pas les abscisses–
et vous savez que l'Allemagne
a décidé de sortir du nucléaire.
Alors question:
Pouvez-vous me dire à quoi correspond cette année là?
Alors une première suggestion, c'est Tchernobyl.
Deuxième suggestion, c'est Fukushima.
Hé bien la réponse est ni l'un, ni l'autre.
C'est le début du plan Schröder.
Fukushima c'est là.
Ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'au moment où l'Allemagne
accélère sa sortie du nucléaire au moment de Fukushima,
en fait, elle ne fait qu'entériner un truc qui a démarré des années avant,
au début des années 2000,
et un truc que Merkel avait essayé d'arrêter juste avant Fukushima.
Puis avec Fukushima, elle a dit: c'est bon, on plie.
Alors ici vous avez un pays qui pour le moment n'a pas vraiment décidé d'arrêter.
C'est la Chine qui concentre aujourd'hui – de mémoire – pas loin de la moitié des réacteurs en construction dans le monde
et qui – comme vous le savez probablement –
a démarré un puis deux EPR
le deuxième venant d'entrer en service il ya quelques semaines.
Ici, vous avez la Corée du Sud
qui a – on le verra un peu plus tard –
une fraction assez significative de son électricité qui provient du nucléaire
qui aussi récemment s'est tâtée:
est-ce que je sors est-ce que je ne sors pas?
Ici vous avez le Royaume-Uni.
Le Royaume-Uni est un exemple intéressant de pays qui a
très envie d'avoir du nucléaire,
qui en a globalement actuellement plutôt de moins en moins, par défaut d'investissements.
Vous savez probablement que le Royaume Uni est un pays
dit assez libéral, c'est-à-dire qu'on compte beaucoup sur le privé pour faire des choses.
Et on verra un peu plus tard que le nucléaire,
par opposition au charbon et au gaz,
a la particularité d'avoir une structure économique
dans laquelle il faut payer à peu près tout avant de démarrer la centrale.
Vous avez une énorme part de l'investissement
et derrière une part relative des coûts de fonctionnement qui est très faible.
Et quand vous êtes dans un contexte dans lequel il faut payer à peu près tout avant de démarrer la centrale
c'est un contexte dans lequel, dans le monde du capital privé, ça aura du mal à se faire.
Dit autrement, le capital privé, il aime bien pas trop attendre pour voir
le rendement de l'argent arrivé en retour.
donc quand il faut mettre plein d'argent
Construire 8 ans, éventuellement 10 ans, éventuellement 12 ans,
avant de commencer à avoir un euro de chiffre d'affaires,
c'est des trucs que le privé n'aime pas du tout.
Et donc le fait en Grande Bretagne d'avoir mis dans le domaine privé
–comme dans beaucoup d'autres endroits en Europe mais encore plus tôt que les autres –
le système de production électrique
a conduit à un défaut d'investissement
– il s'est passé exactement le même processus dans le train en Grande Bretagne –
– en ce moment ils sont en train de faire machine arrière toute –
mais il n'empêche qu'on paye ce défaut d'investissement
avec le fait que le nucléaire que les Grands-Bretons aiment bien a vu sa part baissé.
Ici vous avez un pays qui a
également un parc nucléaire significatif vous verrez même après qu'il a une singularité ce pays c'est la suède
donc la suède à une production nucléaire conséquente et alors vous voyez ici
c'est une année où les suédois ont décidé de sortir du nucléaire
ils ont fait un référendum et puis ils ont dit qu'ils décident de sortir du nucléaire
ça vous fait rire vous avez raison de rire en fait je le sens de le
la contrepartie de ce que j'ai dit sur le fait que le nucléaire était un système qui était très lent à s'installer
c'est que c'est aussi un système qui une fois qu'il est en place
le nucléaires amorties et dans un truc extrêmement pêcheurs là pour le coup c'est très peu cher le nucléaire est amorti
s'en passer comme ça en disant on va on va s'en débarrasser et puis en fait on va le remplacer puis ça va pas nous
coûter cher et malheureusement quelque chose de très difficile enfin malheureusement ou heureusement je ne sais pas mais c'est quelque chose de très difficile
et on verra quand fait une fois qu'on a mis le doigt dans le nucléaire c'est pas facile d'en sortir rapidement
ce qui est pas nécessairement quelque chose de très gênant mais c'est une caractéristique de qu'il faut avoir en tête
Ici c'est pareil vous avez la suisse alors la suisse cette année là elle fait un référendum dans l'autre sens elles
il y avait à l'époque alors les suisses ils font c'est assez rigolo ils font un pas en avant un pas en arrière
Donc là où j'ai cercle et en rouge c'est une année où il dit oui disent
on se donne le droit
avant il y avait un moratoire sur la construction de nouvelles centrales nucléaires c'est à dire le cadre législatif en suisse et est de dire
on s'interdit de construire de nouvelles centrales
puis en 2003 il vote en disant on s'autorise éventuellement à
construire de nouvelles centrales si on veut envoyer le résultat sur la production tout à fait nul
juste ils ont dit où on en fait si on veut
la paix récemment ils ont voté dans l'autre sens en disant on décide d'en sortir
et d'ici à ce que je meure il n'est pas complètement exclu qu'il recherche d'avis au moins une fois
Ici vous avez le cren alors l'ukraine est un pays que vous connaissez à bout
puisque c'est dans ce pays qu'on a eu
charles habile à north shore mobile est cerné cercle et l'a
donc ce que peu de gens savent c'est que après tchernobyl ukraine a doublé sa production nucléaire
C'est assez amusant enfin je sais pas si tu en as ville est amusant mais c'est assez amusé cette anecdote est assez amusant
voilà donc la première premier
là c'était juste un rapide tour de piste pour vous montrer qu'en ce qui concerne le nucléaire
on a des évolutions selon les pays
qui sont contrastées qui ne correspondent pas nécessairement à l'idée qu'on en a dans un sens comme dans l'autre
Alors maintenant on peut ranger les pays qui font du nucléaire de plusieurs manières
la première manière qu'on peut avoir de les ranger c'est de les ranger par production en valeur absolue
donc là ce que vous voyez si on les range en valeur absolue c'est que le premier pays au monde en
production nucléaire c'est les états unis
où nucléaire
représente à peu près 20% ne verra pas juste après de la production électrique et ils ont une production en valeur absolue qui reprit
pardon à peu près le double
De la production française pour plus semaine ils ont une centaine de réacteurs en activité
dans ce pays
après on peut ranger par part
dans la production électrique alors à ce moment vous voyez qu'effectivement la france arrive en tête enfin vous avez quelques pays qui arrive juste derrière
avec la production nucléaire qui représente une grosse moitié
de la production électrique donc ils sont pas à 75 70 % mais ils sont quand même à 50
après on peut les rangées encore d'une autre manière et alors là je pense que vous allez découvrir un truc que vous ne saviez pas
c'est en production en valeur absolue par personne c'est à dire la quantité de kilowattheures nucléaire utilisée par personne et par an dans un pays
hélas ce que vous voyez c'est que le pays qui arrive en tête du classement c'est pas du tout la france la suède
donc la suède est le pays au monde
qui a la plus grosse qu'à pas cité installé par personne en nucléaire est la plus grosse production annuelle par personne en nucléaire
oui
Oui ça veut aussi dire que ils ont des consommations électriques par personne très élevé absolument ils sont un peu après ils sont un peu
après la norvège
qui a une consommation de mémoire la norvège et une consommation électrique par personne qui est le triple de celle de la france
et les suédois se baladent quelque part entre le double électrique
Alors maintenant on va
Rentrer un peu plus dans le détail
la fission comme je vous le disais c'est une manière d'exploiter le fait que quand vous casser un très gros noyau en deux
ça va vous libérer de l'énergie alors en pratique
il ya deux de première chose à savoir c'est que la fission n'arrive qu'à des noyaux qui ont un numéro atomique
supérieur à 89 et par ailleurs ça n'est possible qu'avec des isotopes un père
donc par exemple l'uranium 238 ne fonctionne pas l'uranium 239 235 oui le plutonium 239
fils yonne le plutonium 246 y est pas et c'est d'accord dont vous avez un
les isotopes les isotopes père ne d'officiels pas
Alors dans la majeure partie des cas
cette fiction il faut la provoquer aléas c'est allé assez rare et donc l'équation général d'une fiction c'est ça
c'est vous avez un noyau d'uranium qui capturent à neutrons ça lui donne une indigestion et il va éclater en
n morceaux alors n ces deux gros x et y
plusieurs très petit quelques neutrons et du rayonnement gamma
donc ici vous avez votre noyau fissiles de départ là vous avez le neutron
qu'il est capable d'absorber alors après je rouge
et le dire tout de suite je sais pas si j'y reviens plus tard ce neutre où
tous les noyaux fils ils ne sont pas capables de fissionner avec tous les types de neutrons
vous avez deux catégories de neutrons dans un réacteur nucléaire vous avez les neutrons qu'on appelle rapide
les neutrons rapides c'est les neutrons à l'énergie qu'ils ont juste après la fission qui les a créés donc là quand la fission a lieu
et au moment où elle a lieu
eh bien le neutron les nôtres ans qui sont éjectés là ils ont une énergie de quelques millions d'électron volts
et ces neutrons à quelques millions d'électron volts
il ya des atomes fit signe qu'ils sont capables de les absorber quand ils passent à proximité dont vous avez le federer de
La capture de notre monde quelle que soit la vitesse ils l'attrapent
et puis vous avez moi c'est à dire que si ça passe trop vite à ma portée je le sais rien d'en faire il faut
que ça allait lentement pour que je sois capable d'aller le chercher
et ces neutrons qui passent lentement on les appelle des neutrons thermique ça veut dire qu'ils ont une énergie cinétique de l'ordre de l'électro vote
beaucoup beaucoup moins que le million d'électronvolts qu'ils ont au moment où ils ont été créés
Vous avez donc la création de ce qu'on appelle les produits de fission donc les produits de fission c'est les deux noyaux
qui sont issus de la fission de l'uranium
des neutrons
1,4 et du rayonnement gamma alors voilà un exemple
là vous avez un noyau d'uranium qu'ils fissent yonne et qui vous fait
un noyau de krypton qui soit dit en passant et gazeux donc dans les produits de fission
vous avez des produits qui sont gazeux qui vont spontanément à ce moment
parce que chimiquement et s'associe à rien
sortie à vouloir sortir du coeur
Vous avez
du baryum et puis ici vous avez 4 neutrons et du rayonnement gamma donc c'est l'équation général de la fission ça ressemble toujours ça ressemble
toujours à ça
vos produits de fission
la nature a décidé de faire un peu de biodiversité dessus
et donc vous n'avez jamais exactement les mêmes à chaque fission d'accord donc en fait les produits de fission ils sont
Il couvre une très très large variété de numéros atomique comme vous le voyez là cela étant ils sont quand même centré
sur
deux il ya deux pics il ya deux endroits où vous allez préférentiellement retrouver vos produits de fission
Vous allez en gros les retrouver donc le radium initial 1 ses 81
et donc en gros vous allez retrouver 30 et 60 à l'arrivée
je dis bien en gros les neutrons ça compte pas évidemment talent numéro atomique
donc à l'arrivée vous allez retrouver 30 et 60 en ordre de grandeur
Donc vous allez retrouver en particulier de l'yonne alors beaucoup de ces produits de fission radioactif
vers trouvé de l'yonne du césium du strontium du 70e et c'est
Les produits de fission donc l'essentiel sont radioactifs avec des demi vie
qui vont de quelques
enfin d'une fraction de seconde
jusqu'à des milliers d'années donc il ya un peu de il ya un peu de tout là dedans
L'essentiel des produits de fission ondes et demi vit quand même qui n'excède pas quelques dizaines d'années
la radioactivité
des produits de fission est quand même une radioactivité qui décroît très vite on va le voir on va le voir derrière
Ce que vous avez
Part donc dans une fiction
je sais pas si j'allais de là dessus ce que vous allez créer également
quand vous avez changé d'avis là dessus alors j'ai quand même vous en parler rapidement
quand
les neutrons qui sont créées par votre mission
il y en a une partie également qu'ils vont être absorbées par les noyaux d'uranium que vous avez dans le réacteur et en particulier l'uranium
238 et qui vont vous créez des épisodes des noyaux dont le numéro atomique et au delà de l'uranium
en plutonium du proc tignes hommes de l'américium du curium du etc
ces trucs là vous savez dans le tableau de mendeleïev ça s'appelle des actinides
et souvent on appelle ça des activit mineur parce que de fait ils sont présents en petites quantités dans le dans le
Dans la barre de combustible ça dans la barbe
doxi d'uranium
c'est
actinides certains vont officio des encours de
réaction soit dit en passant d'autres non et donc vous allez récupérer dans le combustible usé qu'on ressort à la fin
je le disais l'uranium 235
lui il il aime bien les neutrons thermique
donc au moment où ils sont éjectés les neutrons sont trop énergétique pour être utilisé par un autre noyau d'uranium 235 encore l'idée c'est que
une fission d'uranium 235 les neutrons qui sont émis à l'occasion de cette fiction
vous vous en servier pour aller fissionner ensuite d'autres noyaux d'uranium 235 d'accord
alors ça veut dire deux choses cette histoire là ça veut dire d'abord que le noyau qui valait fissionner
pendant le neutron qui va aller fissionner un nouveau noyau d'uranium 235 il doit pas aller trop vite sinon ça marche pas
ariane 235 il est comme moi sont pas faits derrière donc mis ses pas attraper les neutrons qui vont trop vite
et donc il faut le ralentir dans un premier temps et alors pour ça
on va utiliser ce qui s'appelle un modérateur
et le modérateur c'est juste jouer au billard avec le neutron qui a été créée
jusqu'au moment où il a perdu suffisamment d'énergie pare-chocs élastique sur d'autres petits noyaux
pour devenir un autre enterrement qui vous savez que quand vous avez un choc élastique entre deux
objets de même masse c'est là que vous perdez le plus d'énergie cinétique dans l'objet incident
vous en rappeler de ça
Quand vous avez un choc élastique sur un mur parfait vous perdez rien d'accord donc si vous avez une masse infinie en face de vous
choquer lastic vous perdez absolument pas d'énergie
le maximum d'énergie c'est un exercice de mécanique classique ça c'est un maximum d'énergie vous allez le père quand vous tapez contre un truc qui
a exactement votre pass
si vous tapez contre un truc qui a une masse microscopique
vous perdez très peu d'énergie aussi le truc par contre l'autre truc part à toute vitesse mais ça rapporte pas beaucoup d'énergie il faut vous
tapiez sur un truc qui a la même masse que vous alors qu'est-ce qui a la même masse que un
neutron et bien un autre neutrons ou un proton
donc le meilleur modérateur qu'on ait ces les noyaux d'hydrogène
de l'eau
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle le modérateur qu'on met dans un réacteur
excellence c'est juste de l'eau qui soit dit en passant sert aussi de caloporteur il sert aussi à évacuer la chaleur
Du coup vous avez un élément de sécurité
passive c'est que si vous perdez une calotte si vous perdez part dans lequel au porteur et une fuite dans le circuit par exemple
certes vous n'êtes plus capable de refroidir votre coeur mais par ailleurs la fiction s'arrête
C'est un élément de sécurité passive important
Je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que une fission ça faisait entre 1 et 4 noteront si vous voulez que votre réaction en chaîne
soit stable c'est à dire qu'au cours du temps elle vous produisent toujours la même quantité d'énergie
il faut que le 1 à 4 neutrons que vous avez produit lors d'une fiction se transforme en un
neutron capturé par un autre noyau d'uranium 235 et justin
si vous faites captures ci à partir d'un noyau
qui fit sione vous fait capturer deux neutrons par deux autres noyaux puis 4 puis 8 puis etc ça s'appelle une bombe
D'accord vous avez un truc qui diverge très vite et c'est soit dit en passant exactement le principe de la bombe atomique
dans la bombe atomique vous avez les premières fictions
qui font une réaction en chaîne qui va très très vite et tout ça fait beaucoup
alors dans un réacteur ça peut pas aller jusqu'au niveau d'une bombe atomique mais ça peut quand même
fiche le truc en l'air c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé à tchernobyl
et donc si vous voulez pas que ça arrive eh bien il faut que
quand vous avez plus d'un neutron qui est créée par la réaction de fission
les neutrons excédentaires
soient absorbés par quelque chose qu'il ya dans le réacteur et qui vous permet de n'avoir à l'arrivée qu'un seul nouveaux neutrons
pour fissionner un autre noyau d'uranium 235
et dont vous avez dans un réacteur outre la matière fissile
deux constituants qui sont absolument essentielles qui sont d'une part des absorbeur de neutrons notamment le bord
et d'autre part un modérateur
typiquement de l'autre vous avez des réacteurs dans lesquelles le modérateur et du graphite
mais aujourd'hui on fait plus ça pour plein de raisons
dont le fait que si vous perdez le caloporteur vous perdez pas le modérateur et donc ça empêche pas la réaction de continuer à se
produire donc là vous êtes dans un très mauvais cap figure dans lequel la réaction continue à se produire
et vous n'avez pas de quoi refroidir le coeur
donc les réacteurs à grafite et tuant la ville grafite
vous en trouvez pas en fonctionnement en france je retrouvais en cours de démantèlement mais pas en fonctionnement
voilà donc le but du jeu dans un réacteur c'est que vous ayez en régime permanent exactement un
neutron
capturé par fission
Neutrons capturés pour fissionner à un autre moyen aux partitions si vous voulez faire monter votre réacteurs en puissance
transitoirement vous allez passer de 1 à 1
000 000
1 un tout petit peu plus que 1
et si vous voulez calmer votre réacteurs vous allez faire exactement l'inversé c'est à dire que pendant un temps vous allez passer de 1 à
0,9 9,9
jusqu'au moment où votre truc descend un peu en puissance
De là dedans vous avez également l'émission de rayonnement gamma
Est alors normalement les deux troncs il en sort pas trop du réacteur ce que vous avez absorber avant
par contre vous avez plein rayonnement gamma qui sort du réacteur c'est pour ça qu'un réacteur en fonctionnement vous éviter d'aller vous promener à côté
et donc que vous avez une enceinte de confinement
qui est autour du donc le réac tout ça c'est dans un tube en acier dans une cuve en acier vous avez vos assemblage
d'oxydés d'uranium et l'eau qui circule autour qui sert à la fois de modérateur et caloporteur
et tout ce truc là qui vous crachent allègrement du gamma émis dans un endroit
à l'intérieur d'un truc en béton
où on est sûr que les gamins vont pas aller se balader à l'extérieur est comme ça y'a pas de problème
Alors
Si j'en parle de l'exactitude alors les actinides donc j'y reviens
c'est le sait les produits plus lourd enfin plus au delà de l'uranium dans tableau périodique des éléments
qui sont créées par absorption successives de neutrons
Et désintégration radioactive
donc là vous avez l'exemple par exemple
vous passez de l'uranium au plutonium en ayant commencé par absorber un neutron alors pardon avait à partir d'uranium 238
c'est comme ça que c'est comme ça que ça marche parce que leur énième 235 encore une fois ci il absorbe les neutrons officiel
je vous rappelle que dans un réacteur vous avez un mélange des deux isotope 235 et 238 dans les réacteurs français
uranium 235 au moment où vous enfourner l'uranium c'est à peu près trois et demi pour cent du total
donc ça veut dire 96 5% c'est d'uranium 238
vous avez des réacteurs dans le monde qui fonctionne avec de l'uranium naturel donc à 0 7 % d'uranium 235
mais à ce moment il vous faut de l'eau bourde en général pour que ça marche
Voilà donc la voilà un truc qui va vous donner du plutonium alors le plutonium peut fissionner
Et à ce moment
vous pouvez imaginer un réacteur
dans lequel vous avez qui est basé non pas sur la fission de l'uranium 235
mais sur la génération en continu de plutonium puis la fission
du plutonium
c'est ça qu'on appelle le surgénérateur donc le surgénérateur
typiquement phénix et superphénix
c'est un réacteur dans lequel c'est l'uranium 238 qui sert de combustible
sauf que il sert de combustible en ayant besoin de deux trous donc c'est un truc qui est plus compliquée à piloter
parce que vous avez vous devez tenir compte c'est pas un truc instantanée vous devez tenir compte des temps de formation
et dépendent décroissance radioactive pour avoir du plutonium derrière
Le l'avantagent par contre c'est que il ya deux avantages à ceux assez réacteur là
le premier c'est que vous n'avez pas besoin de modérateur
typiquement plutonium il sait fissionner avec des neutrons lent et des refrains des neutrons thermique et des neutrons rapides
donc vous n'avez pas besoin de modérer les neutrons corps
et la deuxième c'est que évidemment au lieu de brûler une toute petite partie
de l'uranium fois au lieu de profiter d'une toute petite partie parce que le relais est un terme à trois plus ayem est un métal
au lieu d'utiliser une toute petite partie de l'uranium qu'on trouve dans la nature
l'uranium 235 16 07 % de l'uranium qu'on trouve dans la nature
en utilisant des réacteurs de ce type là vous utilisez la totalité du radium qu'on trouve dans la nature
donc pas juste pour rien donc ça veut dire que vous êtes capable de multiplier par un facteur 2 100 en ordre de grandeur
le potentiel énergétique de l'uranium qu'on trouve dans la nature oui
Alors typiquement superphénix s'était du sodium
ça dans les dents c'est rapide la cdu sodium vous avez également une famille de réacteur qui
fonctionne sur
vous avez plusieurs dessins là dedans ou un autre c'est cette fondue donc en fait vous avez un grand bain dans lequel tout est mélangé
enfin
mais le
les réacteurs rapide qu'on a fait fonctionner longtemps en france donc il ya eu un réacteur industriels qui s'appelait superphénix mais qui a été démantelée
ça qui a été arrêté au titre d'un compromis politique est
démantelée par contre y en a un autre qui est des plus petits qui s'appelait félix qui lui a fonctionné pendant 30 ans
de façon tout à fait normal et on va dire
mais qui a aussi été arrêté et qui est en cours enfin de démantèlement
Alors oui comme ça je viens de vous le dire on peut également se servir du thorium
dans le même dans le même esprit
donc le thorium après absorption d'un autre on se transforme en uranium 233 et l'uranium 233 et sicile
donc c'est exactement le même principe que avec le plutonium ce qui veut dire qu'il ya deux couples
dans la nature qui peuvent servir à faire des réacteurs nucléaire à neutrons rapides et surgénérateur c'est
uranium plutonium
ou
thorium uranium
mais c'est pas de la mise au top 1 233
alors cela étant
ces éléments donc l'uranium 238 et le thorium 232 comme il faut leur envoyer des neutrons pour qu'il se mette à fissionner
ça veut dire que vous devez avoir une source de neutrons
pour démarrer la réaction
donc en fait on ne peut pas démarrer un réacteur nucléaire
juste avec de l'uranium 238 ou avec du thorium 232 on est obligés de démarrer avec un truc qui fusionne
naturellement dans l'uranium 235 et c'est une fois que le truc a démarré qu'on peut rajouter derrière
quelque chose de l'uranium 238 ou du thorium
Donc en gros
cdc des cycles
qui permettent d'augmenter le potentiel d'une énergie nucléaire qui existe déjà à base d'uranium
235 mais ça permet pas de la remplacer en totalité
oui
Ciba en partie le son c'est ce que j'ai expliqué avant il le soit et c'est comme ça que vous faites vos actinides
Une partie le plutonium une partie va fissionner dans le réacteur et une partie va rester dans l'assemblage quand vous le sortez en fin d'exploitation
on verra ça au moment des déchets
C'est exactement ce que je vous ai montré alors j'y reviens si c'est pas clair là
D'accord je vous ai dit en fait
l'uranium qui est capable de monter dans le tableau périodique des éléments c'est l'uranium
238 en gros si assez simple l'uranium 235 voulant rien de très officiel
donc il peut pas monter en numéro atomique puisqu'ils fonctionnent
donc le seul qui peut monter en numéro atomique c'est l'uranium 238 il absorbe un autre on après il vous faut une désintégration bêta moins
et du coup ça vous créant protons dans le noyau est donc là ça monte en numéro atomique
Et donc vous allez vous allez monter comme ça
On mâche un crac crac crac vous allez créer
Qu'est ce que je veux dire du plutonium du neptunium du enfin voilà vous avez créé des
des éléments qui sont l'amérique y sommes dues curium machin comme ça qu'ils s'appellent tous des actinides
Alors dans les réacteurs actuels
une petite partie fils yonne mais dans les déchets en sortie de réacteurs vous allez en trouver quand même
dans le combustible usé en sortie des réacteurs vous allez en trouver quand même
dans les dessins imaginés
pour une partie de la génération 4
eh bien
il ya des gens qui souhaitent qu'on fasse des réacteurs dans lequel ces trucs là sont brûlés au fur et à mesure qu'ils sont produits
Ce qui est possible
Alors parlons de génération justement
Les générations c'est comme les versions de windows donc ça sur le même principe mais on dit que ça s'améliore
donc vous avez eu
génération 1 c'était les réacteurs à uranium naturel graphite gaz
il y en a un certain nombre qui ont été conçus en france ils ont tous été arrêtés au moment où ce qui tenait lieu
d'autorités de sûreté
pas au sens où ça ne faisait pas vraiment de la sûreté ou ça parce que ça s'appelait pas autorité de sûreté
a dit edf ces trucs là on trouve que c'est pas terrible donc vous bien vous mettez télé vous faites tel et tel type de
travaux de mise en conformité ou s'arrêter et des f a fait ses calculs et a dit on arrête
donc vous avez déjà eu en france une première vague d'arrêt de réacteurs
avant terme
pas du tout pour des raisons politiques pas du tout parce qu'on a dit c'est hyper dangereux etc
et puis tu es les lecteurs soient très bien qu'on les arrête pas du tout
c'est l'autorité de sûreté qui a dit ça ça ne va pas donc travaux de mise en conformité ou art est à dire
la deuxième réaction à la deuxième génération c'est celle qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est essentiellement des réacteurs en france à eau pressurisée l'autre grand dessein c'est les réacteurs à eau bouillante
La troisième génération c'est en fait du de plus parce que ça change pas tellement dans le concept
donc c'est le p r ou d'autres trucs de cette nature
et enfin
il ya un certain nombre de gens
qui réfléchissent
à la génération d'après qui aujourd'hui est un est un
concept au sens où la génération d'après on lui a donné un cahier des charges
qui est
exploité tout l'uranium ferme et cycle c'est à dire
ne pas sortir des trucs qui peuvent encore servir du combustible usé
typiquement le plutonium ça peut encore servir on peut encore tirer de l'énergie du plutonium donc c'est dommage de sortir du combustible usé du réacteur
et puis d'aller mettre ça directement dans un trou dans un stockage de déchets 100 recyclé s'en extraire de
ce combustible ce qu'on peut encore utiliser valorisé à des fins énergétiques
et minimiser les déchets et sécurité passive enfin et surtout pas sifflé exactement un réacteur donc un certain nombre de trucs on vas y ça
doit satisfaire à ça ça et ça donc
il ya déjà d un certain nombre de concepts qui sont explorées en ce moment
Voici un assemblage d'uranium ces lieux si j'affiche
Tels que
Telles qu'on les utilise dans les réacteurs français donc là vous avez des grands tubes en eau en dire que nous sommes
en alliage de dirk omnium plus exactement à l'intérieur duquel vous avez des pastilles des oxydes d'uranium c'est comme ça que c'est
comme ça que c'est enfourner l'eau peut circuler entre ça s'appelle des crayons là c'est petit c'est petit tube est ce que vous remarquez
c'est un truc intéressant à savoir
c'est que cet opérateur manipule cet assemblage alors pas à mains nues pour permettre des traces de graisse mais sans aucune protection radiologique
donc en fait l'uranium au moment où il est enfourné dans le réacteur nous présente aucune radio toxicité particulière
corsa radioactivité naturelle n'est pas tel que il faille s'en protéger
Alors si on parle d assemblage et de la manière dont c'est fait voilà en gros à quoi ça ressemble donc l'uranium à qom toutes
les ressources que nous utilisons dans notre système économique
elle est
gratuite
corps donc l'uranium c'est gratuit ça a été fait par mère nature
ou est-ce que ça a été fait par mère nature
Pardon ah non lors du big man on n'avait que des protons
Non mais j'ai entendu un truc qui commence à se rapprocher pas dans le soleil puisque le soleil pour
importer de l'uranium du soleil actuelle sur terre c'est un peu compliqué
Mais pardon
dans les anciennes étoiles exactement ça a été fait dans la génération précédente des toiles
si on retrace l'univers l'histoire de l'univers sur les 14 derniers milliards d'années
d'abord vous avez le big bang une grande soupe de protons
la première génération des toiles et dans cette première génération des toiles par fusions successives vous avez tout le tableau de mendeleïev qui se crée
là dessus les étoiles pour certaines d'entre elles vous font des très belles supernovae bazar tout ça dans l'espace
et une deuxième génération des étoiles se forment enfin il s'enflamme en permanence mais je veux dire et ces poussières
issues de la première génération des toiles
vont pour partie allait se mettre en orbite autour de la deuxième génération des toiles se condenser et faire des planètes telluriques
typiquement la terre
donc pour faire une terre avec 92 éléments du tableau de mendeleïev faut attendre dix milliards d'années après le big bang
recettes de cuisine qui prend un peu de temps
et c'est gratuit donc l'uranium est gratuit comme tout le reste il faut juste aller le chercher
alors allé le chercher ça va se faire comme pour tous les métaux dans des endroits où il ya des concentrations particulière
vous trouver n'importe quel métal n'importe où
si vous n'êtes pas regardant sur la concentration c'est à dire que si j'extrais un mètre cube de terre là dessous l'école des mines
je vais probablement y trouver tous les éléments du tableau de mendeleïev
mais certains sont mais ils sont présents dans des concentrations tels que j'en ferai jamais rien donc quand ils sont présents
plus concentré qu'ailleurs ça s'appelle une mine
dans une mine vous allez chercher
de l'uranium
vous allez le chercher sous forme d' occident en général comme
mais vous avez tout un tas d'autres trucs qui vous intéressent absolument pas donc d'abord vous sortez votre minerais et vous concentrer
ce qui vous intéresse
une fois que vous avez récupéré votre radium vous allez faire une
encore une fois sous forme de site vous allez faire une opération qui s'appelle l'enrichissement pour les réacteurs français
alors l'enrichissement est un mélange compliqué de chimie et de physique
qui consiste à prendre préférentiellement dans l'uranium l'isotope 235
comme l'isotope 235 à très exactement les mêmes propriétés chimiques que l'isotope 238
puisque les propriétés chimiques ça dépend du nombre de protons ont donc d'électrons
il faut trouver un moyen pour séparer ses deux isotopes qui n'est pas un moyen chimiques
vous pouvez pas purifier chimiquement de l'isotope 235 ça marche pas donc la façon dont ça marche c'est avec des centrifugeuses
alors notez bien ce que je vais vous dire parce que c'est le grand débat sur la prolifération
une centrifugeuse c'est quoi c'est un petit cylindre dans lequel vous faites tourner
de l'hexafluorure d'uranium
gaz et vous allez mettre une écope
à l'extérieur du cylindre et une écope à l'intérieur du cylindre enfin près de l'axé de rotation
une écope c'est un truc qui vous qui vous attrape ce qui passe
les coptes qui est après
après du bord du cylindre va vous prendre préférentiellement de l'uranium 238 parce que à cause de la force centrifuge ou centripète plus exactement le
238 va avoir tendance à être préférentiellement
plus près du bord les plus lourds
et les coqs qui est près de l'axé de rotation vous prend préférentiellement d'u235
alors ce préférentiellement c'est une fraction de pour mille achats dans chaque centre et du jeu
donc il faut les mettre en cascade les unes derrière les autres jusqu'au moment où
ça vous a enrichi pour les coqs du centre votre uranium
préférentiellement en 235 à hauteur de 3% mais c'est exactement la même chaîne qui permet de faire de l'uranium à
99 avec 99 % d'uranium 235 il suffit juste d'en avoir les milliers
et c'est avec ça que les pays qui veulent accéder à l'armé nucléaire en général s'équipent
D'accord donc c'est la même technologie que la technologie civile
de la chaîne du combustible
sont ce que
si vous me réglez suffisamment ça permet de faire une bombe
alors quand le but du jeu n'est pas de faire une bombe
heureusement donc vous séparer votre
radium et du coup une fois vous avez enrichi votre uranium pour
en gros pour avoir une tonne d'uranium enrichi à 3 5%
il vous faut 5 tonnes d'uranium à 0 7%
Derrière vous allez avoir une tonne d'uranium propre à faire du combustible
et 4 tonnes d'uranium qui vous servent entre guillemets à rien il s'appelle de l'uranium appauvri
alors l'uranium appauvri est ce que vous savez qu'elle était une des exploitations qu'on en a fait à un moment
Exactement déleste pour des voiliers de course parce que comme c'est un métal extrêmement dense
ça fait des très grandes masses dans des petits volumes
et ça quand vous faites un voilier course dont vous allez mettre sa très à quatre mètres sous la coque là
et ça vous fait des
voix là je n'ai pas spécialement dangereux
une fois que vous avez votre uranium enrichi
donc vous en faites des pesticides oxyde d'uranium vous mettez ça dans les tubes en alliage de zirconium 1 et ça vous fait les assemblages
que vous mettez dans réacteurs vous laisser produire pendant fissionner pendant quelques années et puis une fois que ces sorties
alors là vous avez deux écoles en fonction du pays où vous êtes vous avez des pays qui disent je prends ça
et ça c'est un déchet
et je le stock quelque part
alors aux états unis sous yucca mountain les suédois y mettre ça dans des fûts en cuivre il colle ça sous terre
et en france on a une autre école qui est de dire on va faire du recyclage là dedans
parce qu'il ya une partie de ce qui s'y trouve qu'on peut remettre dans des assemblages convard et enfourner dans des réacteurs
corps c'est à ça que sert d' usine de la hague
et ce qui sert vraiment à rien eh bien on s'en débarrasse d'une autre manière
c'est ça le sait ça l'école française entre guillemets donc vous avez deux écoles dans le monde
Et ce qui ne sert plus à rien là pour le coup s'appelle vraiment des déchets
alors pour avoir quelques ordres de grandeur des masses en présence
Pour un mégawatt heure électrique vous avez besoin de 10 kg 2 une règle qui vont vous donner quelques grammes
d'uranium donc vous voyez c'est quand même la concentration oui
La valeur de trois et demi
non non c'est ce qui permet de piloter une réaction de fission de façon confortable j'ai envie de dire si vous en mettez
90% ça vous fait une bombe donc c'est incontrôlable et si vous en mettez pas assez
en fait ça vous fait pas assez de neutrons
Et vous les voulez vous n'êtes pas capable d'avoir votre réaction en chaîne
Donc je disais à partir de 10 kg 2
à faire à partir de 10 kg de minerai
vous à vous avez une grosse dizaine de grammes un peu moins un peu plus une petite vingtaine
d'uranium donc vous voyez que la concentration en uranium du minerai est de l'ordre du pur mille d'accord donc c'est pas des
ehpad et c'est pas des concentrations importantes
c'est l'heure du kg par tonne
vous avez un métal qui est présent encore à des toners encore plus faible quand on exploite c'est
L'or l'or vous est typiquement à quelques grammes par tonne de minerai 10 grammes par tonne donc là vous êtes quand même très au dessus
Donc
On va faire deux autres affaires de l'uranium enrichi
et avec ça
vous allez faire votre votre mégawattheure ce que ça vous montre ce genre de
ce genre de diagrammes c'est notamment encore une fois que vous avez besoin de manipuler de toutes petites quantités
de matière pour faire des grandes quantités d'électricité
C'est vraiment par excellence la caractéristique du nucléaire
Bien évidemment
vous avez
un rendement énergétique
de votre affaire
exactement comme pour le pétrole où vous devez utiliser une partie de l'énergie extraite pour pomper le pétrole
le raffiner le transporter en ce qui concerne l'uranium
vous avez besoin d'une partie de l'énergie fournie alors pas sous la même forme parce qu'en l'occurrence dans les mines c'est du pétrole mais
vous avez besoin d'une partie d'énergie fournie pour faire fonctionner la chaîne vous avez besoin de la du diesel dans les engins de mines
de l'électricité dans l' usine d'enrichissement etc et donc il ya une question qui est quel est le rendement énergétique de l'ensemble
est ce que on consomme 90 % d'énergie qu'on produit dans la chaîne ou est ce que on en consomme
juste une petite partie est donc ce que vous montre ce graphique c'est qu'on n'en consomment en fait juste une petite partie le rendement typique
de la de la filière nucléaire
c'est de l'ordre de 1 pour 50 ou 1 %
c'est à dire que la fraction de l'énergie qui est utilisé dans l'ensemble du cycle pour permettre à l'énergie nucléaire d'être produite
c'est de l'ordre de 1 à 2 % de l'énergie produite
c'est de cet ordre là
en fait c'est extrêmement dépendant de la teneur en minerai
de la teneur en uranium par lots du minerai
ce que vous disent
ce graphique c'est que aux teneurs actuelles on se balade plutôt par là
de minerais mais si vous avez des minerais suffisamment pauvres
eh bien il faut charrier une telle quantité de terre
et purifier une telle quantité de
matière que vous pouvez évidemment vous rapprocher d'un rendement qui serait de l'ordre de
leur bel assez logarithmique un oui donc en gros il faut perdre un facteur 100
Dans la teneur en uranium du minerai pour que votre affaire commence à ne plus être intéressante donc on en est évidemment encore extrêmement loin
Par ailleurs quand vous avez comme vous avez besoin de toutes petites quantités de entre guillemets combustible pour produire des grandes quantités d'électricité
le nucléaire est une industrie qu'on appelle à coûts fixes dit autrement
l'essentiel du coût économique de production du nucléaire c'est dans la construction de la centrale
et dans la construction des installations amont et aval qui permettent de fonctionner
les coûts variables
et notamment les coûts de combustible sont des coûts extrêmement faible
dans la chaîne dit autrement une fois que vous avez construit votre centrale qu'elle fonctionne ou qu'elle fonctionne pas ça vous coûte la même chose
et en cela c'est exactement la même structure de coûts qu'une éolienne ou un panneau solaire
une éolienne ou un panneau solaire une fois que vous l'avez construit ça vous coûte quasiment plus rien en face ils éoliennes fall et la
maintenir à peu de temps en temps panneaux solaires fois les lui passer un petit coup d'épongé pour enlever la poussière de temps en temps
mais globalement
vous avez des coûts de maintenance qui sont faibles
et l'essentiel du coût et dans la construction du dispositif initial et le nucléaire c'est exactement pareil
l'essentiel du coût et dans la construction du dispositif initial
et alors là je vais refaire un tout petit peu de microéconomie
quand vous avez un dispositif où vous devez mettre tout l'argent d'abord
et avoir des clients et des recettes ensuite
le coût auquel vous allez leur vendre le mégawattheure
va dépendre de deux critères de manière absolument centrale 1 le coût de construction vous comprenez bien que si vous construisez pour deux fois plus
cher toutes choses égales par ailleurs vous vendrez pour deux fois plus cher
mais ça dépend également d'un autre
élément qui est absolument centrale
et qui pour ceux d'entre vous qui ont vu passer un crédit immobilier
ça vous rappellera des souvenirs qui est ce qu'on appelle le coût de l'argent c'est à dire le taux d'intérêt
que vous devez payer soit votre actionnaire soit votre banquier pour l'argent qui vous a été fourni pour construire la centrale
Donc en gros quand vous construisez une centrale votre argent ils tombent pas du ciel
Votre argent il vient de deux sources et de sources seulement
votre actionnaire et votre banquier
donc votre actionnaire investi dans le projet il investit dans la centrale puis il très bien j'ai mis mon argent mais tous les ans
je veux que ça me rapporte des dividendes
je gagnais de l'argent
et votre banquier va vous dire exactement la même chose je viens vous prêtez de l'argent
mais à condition que tous les ans vous me payer les intérêts
sur la partie vous m'avez pas encore remboursé
et alors ce que vous dit le graphique que je vous affiche maintenant
c'est combien ça vous coûte en euros par mégawattheure pour une centrale qui de mémoire était à
5000 euros le kilo watt installé
en fonction du loyer
de l'argent
donc ce que vous voyez c'est que si on vous prête l'argent gratuitement
même avec un de paix est reconstruit cher et hors délai et bien le remboursement de l'investissement c'est 20 euros le mégawattheure
Corps donc ce n'est pas beaucoup
par contre si vous avez un banquier ou un actionnaire
qui vous dit ouais moi je considère que c'est vachement risqué cette histoire donc je vais vous demander 10 %
donc tout l'argent que vous me devez encore ou que gérer ce que le lait s'est investi dans la boîte
eh bien tant qu'il est là c'est 10 % par an que vous devez me payer
C'est le rendement du capital et bien si vous êtes à 10% la part de l'investissement dans le coup du mégawattheure frise les 100 euros
donc une très grosse différence entre le nucléaire pas cher et le nucléaire cher c'est tout bêtement
combien est-ce que les actionnaires et les banquiers vont vous demander en taux d'intérêt sur l'argent qui vous est nécessaire pour construire la centrale
et avec ce petit graphique
vous pouvez faire le calcul inverse en ce qui concerne les 'points vous avez pas qu'ils aient entendu parler d'une clé politis y
ait l'épaule c'est une centrale que les
anglais sont en train de construire et c'est une filiale d'edf qui est en train de le faire donc cdf énergie qui est le
plus gros électricien anglais une filiale d'edf qui est en train de construire est alors dans le milieu
des gens qui s'intéressent à la question électrique
les gens qui n'aiment pas le nucléaire vous explique que c'est horriblement cher et que les pognes parce que ça va produire des mégawattheure à
110 euros
alors rendez vous contre 110 euros c'est très cher beaucoup plus cher que d'autres trucs
en fait avec ce petit graphique vous êtes capable de savoir que ça vaut 110 euros le mégawattheure parce que les actionnaires et les banquiers
de vente 10% rendement sur capital investi
et c'est exactement ça tu restes vous posez la question c'est exactement symptômes oui
Parce que la part du
ce que je veux dire parce que la part du
capital dans la structure de coûts n'est pas la même en fonction et
la longue la durée de construction et la durée de vie ne sont pas la même non plus
donc en fait ça dépend également de la durée de construction de la diorite liste
C'était en fait j'aurais dû effacer les autres courses était pas tellement le sujet le sujet c'est de montrer que
En ce qui concerne le nucléaire ça augmente très très vite
avec avec le loyer de l'argent avec le taux auquel on vous demande de
rembourser l'argent
par ailleurs le rendement des capitaux et c'est aussi pour ça que le nucléaire même pas l'investissement privé
le rendement des capitaux qu'on vous demande classiquement
dans une entreprise cotée en bourse
se balade aux alentours de 10 12%
Encore oui si on vous demande un rendement sur capital investi aux alentours de 10 12%
et bien si vous êtes une entreprise cotée en bourse et vous faites du nucléaire vous savez pas le faire à moins de 100 euros
mégawattheure
Et c'est juste ça le sujet parce que si vous êtes une société d'état et qu'on vous demande 0
eh bien vous savez le faire alors hors coûts variables vous savez le faire pour beaucoup moins cher que ça
Le nucléaire comme je le disais tout à l'heure ne suppose pas d'oxydé des atomes de carbone pour obtenir la source primaire d'énergie du coup
c'est une énergie dont le
les émissions de co2 par mégawattheure sont faibles
alors il ya quand même un peu de co2 en analyse de cycle de vie parce que comme je le disais tout à l'heure il
ya des engins de mines qui utilise du diesel il ya du transport du minerai enfin du transport du combustible
il ya des gens qui viennent bosser à la centrale en voiture il faut construire la centrale est donc couler du béton et donc il
faut le faire donc des cimenteries des aciéries
il faut traiter les déchets à laval donc enfin on va
donc tout ça fait que vous avez quand même des petites émissions de co2 à droite et à gauche
mais quand même vous voyez que c'est des émissions qui sont
significativement plus faible que celle des modes concurrents fossiles notamment l'inite charbon et gaz
vous voyez qu'on est
significativement en dessous
d'eux des valeurs qu'on a pour ce mode là
Alors maintenant
Je vais vous montrer
non ça je peux augmenter parce que j'ai pas le temps je vais vous montrer ça plutôt d'après je vous montre à la même chose
Dans le coût carbone est essentielle il est dans l'amont du cycle et dans la mine d'aminé l'enrichissement oui
Assez carbon capture and storage c'est le truc dont j'ai parlé la dernière fois
Alors le coup co2 du démantèlement est très faible
parce que le démantèlement s'est essentiellement passée avec une scie à diamant et découpez le truc
quand vous faites du démantèlement vous n'avez pas besoin de fonte de l'acier
vous n'avez pas besoin de faire du ciment vous n'avez pas besoin d'avoir des engins de mines qui vous
extrait une tonne pour récupérer 10 kg de minerai à l'arrivée
donc en fait c'est s'aider opération qui demande beaucoup de temps parce qu'elles sont très réglementées
mais en termes de flux physiques associés et donc d'émissions de co2 associées
à ces opérations la céder toutes petites quantités
C'est pareil c'est pas ça change pas les ordres de grandeur
en gros le démantèlement d'une installation industrielle compliqué que soit soir centre indre un réacteur nucléaire ou une
win raffinerie c'est 10 à 15 % du coût de construction
c'est très très dépendants du niveau de réglementation applicable donc plus plus vous avez une réglementation qui est contraignante
un exemple typique c'est n'importe quoi qui sort d'une centrale à l'arrêt est considéré comme un déchet nucléaire
d'accord
indépendamment du fait que si je mesure la radioactivité
ce soit effectivement contaminés ou pas bon ben vous avez une
réglementation à la chinoise pragmatique qui dit je mesure 6 et contaminé je stocke si c'est pas contaminer ça va bien et la réglementation française
c'est ça sort du site ces déchets je traite en tant que tel
vous voyez simplement
7,7 différents cela augmente le coût et augmenté les délais
pour la pierre des trucs comme ça vous en avait pléthore
dans dans ce genre d'opération vous avez alors je vous en ai pas pas j'en parlais pas pendant ce court mais
vous avez une centrale aux états unis qui a été ce qu'on appelle retourner au gazon
c'est à dire qu'à la place de l'ancienne centrale vous avez aujourd'hui effectivement un champ corps qui s'appelle maignan qui
donc comme un yankee en américain et mind comme l'état du maine donc allé voir si ça vous intéresse
et en fait l'opération de démantèlement du réacteur a été fait pour 450 millions de dollars si ma mémoire est bonne
sachant que le réacteur 9 août 5 milliards enfin trois oui on est dans ses ordres la 10 15%
et je tiens du patron ne peut pas lui-même à qui j'avais posé la question que pour une raffinerie c'est pareil
c'est 10 à 15% c'est pareil c'est un truc
compliqué avec des tas de produits que vous n'avez pas envie de voir se balader partout dans la nature
même ordre de grandeur
Voilà donc là je vous ai expliqué grosse maille
quel était le principe de l'énergie nucléaire donc encore une fois je répète
pour le couple du sang voilà
Peut-être pas tout écouté jusqu'à maintenant
donc c'est une manière d'obtenir des grandes quantités d'énergie avec très peu de matières sans combustion
ça à cet avantage là ça évidemment des inconvénients
dont je vais vous parler maintenant ça les inconvénients et contrepartie
il ya quelque chose d'intéressant c'est que le nucléaire en france pour des raisons que je vais toujours pas complètement explicité
à une très très forte asymétrie
entre les risques perçus et les risques réels c'est à dire que c'est un domaine dans lesquelles les gens ont très très peur
et vous allez voir que ça se quantifie le fait qu'ils en aient très peur
et se sont plaints de boue et de pleins d'idées qui sont pas conformes au fait vous allez voir aussi que ça se quantifie
D'une
n'existe pas nécessairement dans les autres industries alors vous avez ici lire et celle
qui a posé
c'était en 2014 mais il faut savoir que ces sondages l'art depuis que je les suis ça varie assez peu d'une année sur l'autre
a demandé aux français si un certain nombre de choses étaient
risquer un peu risqué ou pas risquer du tout
donc là c est ce que vous pensez que les risques sont élevés moyennement élevée faible ou bien vous en avais pas la moindre idée
Alors voilà on vous demande ça pour le tabagisme
etc
la drogue l'alcoolisme en faveur des trucs pour lesquelles les gens ont une idée raisonnablement
fiable on va dire du fait que c'est quand même pas terrible et puis voilà quelques sujets qui concerne le nucléaire
est envoyé pour les déchets radioactifs
est bien la population française considère que c'est plus risqué que tout ce que vous avez à droite là
d'accord donc la population française a plus peur des déchets radioactifs que de l'obésité chez les jeunes que des accidents de la route que du
sida que du terrorisme que des ogm que des maladies professionnelles que les installations chimiques
que des produits alimentaires que des innovations et c'est que des incendies de forêts risque médicaux voilà donc tous ces trucs là
pareil pour
alors bon les centrales nucléaires
c'est pas très précis seulement il aurait fallu être peut-être un peu plus précis les vents les retombées en france de tchernobyl
dont je vous parlerai aussi voyez c'est considéré comme étant plus risqué que tous ces trucs là
alors ça c'est la perception de la population
et maintenant on va regarder ce que vous disent les chiffres
alors les chiffres vous disent que le tabac fait de l'ordre de quelques dizaines de milliers de morts prématurées par an
alors pour ceux d'entre vous qui fument dans cette salle bonne nouvelle pas tout de suite encore que
Deuxième bonne nouvelle vous pouvez très bien choper une hémiplégie
un avc donc un accident vasculaire cérébral et une hémiplégie à votre âge voilà j'ai connu ça
avant apparemment personnellement mais je les ai vus se produire donc je sais que c'est possible
Le
Voilà donc ça ça fait soixante dix mille morts par envoyer la drogue
alors les déchets nucléaires à ce jour on fait zéro mort absolument personne n'est mort d'avoir ingéré
c'est cette fête tombait un flux de déchets nucléaires sur la tête
Alors l'obésité il disait chez les jeunes bon alors si on considère que les jeunes finiront par être moins jeunes
ce dont je suis un exemple parmi d'autres ça finira par faire quelques dizaines de milliers de morts par an
oui les accidents de la route
c'est monté jusqu'à 20000 morts par an au milieu des années 70 bon maintenant c'est en nombre de vendeurs dix fois moins
le sida ces quelques centaines le terrorisme ces quelques dizaines enfin en moyenne on va dire
là vous avez des nouveaux héros
Les maladies professionnelles des accidents du travail ces quelques centaines alors là les accidents domestiques josemi 10000 c'est plutôt un bilan fait
donc par exemple les escaliers en france sont considérablement plus de morts que les déchets nucléaires
ça fait à peu près autant de morts par an que les accidents de la route
Le radon est ce que vous savez ce que c'est que le radon
Alors oui
C'est un
Alors cet isotope là et radioactifs absolument
et c'est un
gaz qui apparaît par décroissance radioactive
si ma mémoire est bonne du radium
et que vous trouvez alors qu'ils
provoquent un surplus de cancer du poumon
et c'est un gaz qui est à décroissance radioactive assez rapides donc si vous êtes et il apparaît préférentiellement sur les massifs granitiques
et dans les habitations mal ventilée donc si vous avez vous même ou vos parents ou grands parents oncles tantes etc
une maison mal à la cave mal ventilée en bretagne par exemple ou en auvergne a ni traînez pas trop longtemps encore
parce que c'est des gens n'allaient pas vous y installer
logement quotidien
donc c'est
voilà donc on inhale son on inhale ce gaz
est derrière il va vous bazarder des particules alpha dans les alvéoles qui n'aime pas ça
Donc vous voyez ici que le la hiérarchie des risques
N'est pas du tout perçue comme étant conforme aux données d'observation oui
Là partent tous les déchets nucléaires sont à la hague dans une piscine
Dans les centrales nucléaires c'est pareil vous avez aujourd'hui les travailleurs du nucléaire sont surveillés avec des dosimètres
Et vous avez une limite légale qui est 20 millisieverts par an
voilà je sais pas si je vous avais déjà posé la question est ce que vous savez quel est le salarié français le plus irradiés
Pas mal il s'appelle comment
thomas pesquet
thomas pesquet et le salarié français le plus irradiés
de la totalité des gens qui sont payés dans ce pays
Thomas pesquet prend quand il va faire un séjour de quelques mois dans la station spatiale internationale
que je dise pas de bêtises neuf fois la dose maximale admissible pour un travailleur du nucléaire
Après la deuxième catégorie a effectivement été cité ces deux personnels navigants aérien
qui prend chaque année entre le quart et la moitié de la dose maximale admissible pour un travailleur du nucléaire
Il emporte dosimètres donc voilà donc c'est surveillé
c'est soit dit en passant le personnel aérien navigant n'a pas non plus plus de cancers que la moyenne
Oui
Enfin pas à cause des rayonnements ionisants en tout cas
peut-être d'autres conduites à risque je ne sais pas mais la cause des rayonnements ionisants c'est sûr que non
oui
Je vous en parlerai plus tard oui
Si mais je ne suis pas complètement sûr que s'il n'y avait pas ces composés là ça serait totalement innocents tués
Voilà une autre asymétrie intéressante sur la perception des français et les risques réels là on a demandé aux français est ce que le nucléaire
contribue ou pas aux émissions de gaz à effet de serre
alors vous voyez les gens qui sont en rouge foncé disent beaucoup les gens qui sont en rouge clair disent un peu
Voilà et alors les jeunes filles dans cette salle
sont
l'archétype
des gens qui pensent que ça contribue énormément
Donc tous les gens dans cette salle d'une manière générale le pense plus que la moyenne puisque vous êtes jeune
et que les jeunes ne pensent plus que la moyenne et les femmes le pense plus que les hommes
donc les jeunes ça dans cette salle alors trêve de plaisanterie vous voyez que là on est sûr
je vois comment il faut appeler ça une dissonance cognitive
vous avez une dissociation totale
entre un fait parce que là pour le coup c'est sûr que casser un noyau de métal en deux
c'est pas oxydée un atome de carbone c'est sûr que c'est pas la même chose
Confie alors une explication possible de la part des gens qui suivent ça c'est que comme l'image d'epinal de nucléaire c'est un truc qui fument
bas les gens se disent ce truc là c'est chaud ça fume donc ça a contribué au réchauffement
Complètement idiot de se dire ça une autre explication possible c'est de se dire comme dans notre pays on n'arrête pas de dire
il faut s'occuper du changement climatique et par ailleurs il faut fermer des réacteurs
nucléaires bas les gens boucle la boucle en disant c'est que les réacteurs doivent contribuer au changement climatique
Suivent deux possibilités chez moi
Oui mais les émissions humaines sont totalement marginal dans le cycle naturel de l'eau
je sais pas si vous étiez là où mon du cours sur le changement climatique mais j'en ai parlé pardon
non mais j'en ai parlé de
la lune est une des sources de vapeur d'eau qui modifient significativement le climat local c'est le barrage d'assouan en egypte
parce que là on a fait une sources d'évaporation absolument massive par rapport à la surface du pays
mais les tours de réfrigération des centrales thermiques d'une bonne note que je sois nucléaire ou à charbon c'est totalement inutile au desk dans le
sur une terre qui est couverte aux deux tiers océans
Voilà alors le les inconvénients ou les contreparties on va dire du nucléaire on va en parler un tout petit peu
Maintenant les voici j'ai commencé par dernier
Il ya la question évidemment des ressources puisque il ya un inventaire de départ d'uranium sur terre
exactement comme il ya un inventaire de départ de minerai de cuivre de diamants de platine
et donc la question c'est combien y en a alors comme pour tout métal
qu'il combien il y en a dépend de quelle est la quantité de ressources
énergétiques et donc de ressources économiques que vous êtes prêt à mettre dans l'extraction de ce métal
puisque vous avez des dépôts plus ou moins riches et comme je le disais si vous avez une énergie infinie
et bien il ya de l'uranium sous le sol de l'école des mines d'accord je peux aller je peux y aller et l'extraire
donc une ressource minière c'est toujours quelle quantité pour quels moyens mise en face et alors les moyens mis en face on a coutume de
les assimiler au prix payé
1 en a coutume de tout ramener à d euros en dix ans c'est comme ça qu'on a le meilleur proxy
Donc ce que vous disent
ce
graphique c'est quelque part
que vous avez dans les métaux quelque chose qui ressemble à ce que vous avez dans le pétrole avec du 1p et 2p et 3p
est ce que vous devez retenir comme ordre de grandeur c'est que si on va racler tous les fonds de tiroirs qu'on peut trouver à
droite et à gauche on a de l'ordre de quelques dizaines de millions de tonnes d'uranium disponibles sur terre ou accessibles sur terre
vous en avez aujourd'hui qu'on n'exploite pas par exemple y en a dans les phosphates vous en avez dans l'eau de mer
dans l'aude mais on peut le récupérer avec des polymères qu'on laisse tremper c'est donc vous avez quelques dizaines de millions de tonnes
alors quelques dizaines de millions de tonnes est ce que c'est suffisant pour qu'on colle des centrales nucléaires partout et qu'on soit débarrassé des problèmes
à la fois de disponibilité des combustibles fossiles et du changement climatique finalement c'est ça la règle de trois qui est intéressant ce faire
alors la réponse est
oui et non c'est à dire que si
on considère que l'on reste sur les réacteurs ungg uranium 235 comme aujourd'hui
et bien si vous les augmenter de 5 ou 10 % par an pour faire face aux problèmes que j'ai évoquées dues aux combustibles fossiles
avant la fin du 21e siècle vous avez quand même un prêtre de ressources
par contre si vous passez à partir de ce parc de réacteurs là qui sert à démarrer les
réacteurs de la génération d'après et que vous passez en cycle fermé dans
dans les réacteurs de génération 4 là vous vous y arrivez
c'est à dire que la ressource n'est plus un sujet majeur donc en gros
le sujet central pour un nucléaire entre guillemets durable au sens de sa doit contribuer significativement aux problèmes évoqués précédemment
C'est de passer à la génération d'après qui exploite
l'essentiel du de l'uranium ou qui exploite le thorium qui est quatre fois plus abondant que l'uranium
et à ce moment là densité énergétique du matériau est telle
dans la fission que on a plus de problème de ressources d'ici à ce que l'humanité c'est peut-être
parce que font finira par mourir de quelque chose
Voilà voilà ce que vous dit en gros ce
Graphique
Après on a un sujet en ce qui concerne
le traitement à l'aval du cycle 1
c'est à dire les déchets alors
jusqu'à maintenant j'ai utilisé le oui
Pas non
Non je vous dis à par l'uranium appauvri a servi à faire des quilles de bateaux et des
flèches anti char mais sinon il n'y a pas tellement d'autres c'est pas décoratifs se sent pas spécialement bon
n'en fait pas des oeuvres d'art
C'est ma question je l'étais ans aurait pu servir à autre chose
Oui donc j'ai utilisé le terme combustible jusqu'à maintenant mais il faut bien voir que combustible en fait c'est un terme impropre puisque ça brûle
pas
ça aficion
alors on rassemble âge quand je rentre
j'ai donc de l'uranium à 3 4 % d'uranium 235
je le sors au bout de quelques années
alors j'ai encore de l'uranium mais beaucoup moins est ce que vous voyez c'est que la fraction d'uranium 235 a considérablement baissé
mais il reste encore
mais il en reste encore
J'ai créé du plutonium alors ce plutonium soit dit en passant il y en a une partie qui est fissile c'est du plutonium 239
du plutonium 241 et j'en ai une partie qui n'est pas fils il s'est plutôt nième 240 voir le 242
j'ai tous ces isotopes de plutonium
dans le plutonium que je sors d'une centrale or il se trouve et je vous dis ça en passant
il se trouve que le plutonium qui sert à faire les bombes c'est plutonium 239 à l'exclusion de tous les autres
donc le plutonium que je sors en retraitement
d'une centrale nucléaire est totalement impropres à faire une bombe
pour pouvoir faire des bombes il faut que le plutonium viennent d'un assemblage qui est resté simplement quelques mois dans le coeur du réacteur
c'est pour ça que les centrales qui sont plutôt ni gêne pour faire des bombes
c'est des centrales qu'on appelle à des chargements en continu
c'est à dire que c'est des centrales dans lesquels en cours de fonctionnement je peux chargé du combustible est déchargé du combustible
est soit dit en passant tchernobyl c'était exactement ce type de centrale et c'est pour ça qu'il y avait des
particularités dans le fonctionnement et dessins de ces 30 salle qui la rendait par ailleurs beaucoup plus dangereuse que les centrales qu'on a en france
c'est parce qu'elle avait cet usage là qui était de chargement enfin de fabrication plutonium
et donc qu'elle avait la possibilité d'être chargées et déchargées enfantine
Et vous avez les fameux produits de fission c'est à dire les
Les éléments qui sont centrés autour de numéro atomique 30 et 60 comme je le disais et qui n'ont pas
déjà disparu dans le coeur du réacteur
Alors pour s'appeler ses produits de fission c'est intéressant où les déchets nucléaires c'est intéressant de les comparer à l'ensemble des déchets
que produisent des hommes
parce qu'il n'y a pas qu'avec le nucléaire ont produit des déchets pour fabriquer le t-shirt ou la robe que vous portez il a fallu
faire des déchets aussi les déchets industriels
pour faire vos binettes il a fallu faire des déchets
et pour faire vos chaussures il a fallu faire des déchets et pour faire l'école des mines il a fallu faire des déchets d'accord donc
26 et il ya longtemps
donc la prochaine fois qu'on changera le faux plafond il faudra faire des déchets donc on fait des déchets pour absolument tout
dans notre activité est la question c'est est ce qu'on en fait plus ou moins avec sa
Part personne je dis bien par personne en france nous faisons
2,5 tonnes vous les voyez pas évidemment ils sont pas chez nous de déchets industriels par an
Oui
à cause d'eux et il ya même ces deux
à cause d'eux égale mc2
L'énergie qui a été libéré par la fission correspond à un défaut de masse
a le défaut de masse n'est pas de zéro sinon il y aurait zéro énergie
bon oeil à la mc2 6ème il ya 2 0
c'est au carré a beau être très très grand e et quand même égal à zéro
Donc ses défauts de masse la différence entre les deux
Le oui donc les déchets industriels
qu'on fait c'est deux tonnes et demie par personne et par an en france
c'est la contrepartie encore une fois de la fabrication de tous les objets que vous achetez
au cours d'une une jambe et là dedans il y en a cent qui demandent un traitement des filières spécial
encore un peu les déchets toxiques
Les déchets nucléaires par personne tous types de déchets confondus c'est moins de 1
et là dedans ce qu'ils sont vraiment emmerdant donc ce que on va aller stockés à 6 g au
corps
à burlats dans la meuse cela ils font quelques grammes par français et par an
d'accord donc c'est l'équivalent d'une ou deux pièces de deux euros par français et par an donc retenu
s'est dit d'une autre manière que pour 40 ans d'activité on en fait quelques milliers de mètres cubes ou encore par an
on en fait le volume d'un appartement de trois pièces
d'accord donc la production totale de déchets en mer dans les déchets à haute activité
et à longue durée de vie
on en fait l'équivalent d'un appartement 3 pièces de 100 mètres cubes par personne et par an d'accord 200 mètres cubes
c'est en ordre de grandeur
Ici on a quoi on a dix mètres sur 10 bah on les a dans ces pièces là
on n'a même plus d'accord donc la production annuelle de déchets nucléaires emmerdant en france c'est le volume de ces pièces
Non pour la totale pour la totalité de la france
tout à fait librement par personne ça fait beaucoup pour la totalité de la france
donc c'est des trucs en verlan
mais c'est pas des gros volumes
Alors où est ce qu'ils sont stockées ces déchets nucléaires
ça dépend de leur radiotoxicité donc pour ceux qui sont pas très radioactifs
genre de truc qu'on fait on fait comme des abeilles à l'envers on fait des alvéoles
on vient coller les déchets là dedans alors dans les déchets de faible activité vous avez par exemple les
combinaisons qui ont été utilisées par les opérateurs qui travaillent à la hague voilà ça c'est un exemple de déchets de faible activité
vous avez des résidus vous avez des résidus de traitement
donc là par contre dans le combustible usé là vous n'avez pas de déchets de faible activité ça ça repart dans le cycle du combustible
ça a également et ça ça va directement colis vitrifiés
d'accord donc les déchets de faible et moyenne activité ils viennent pas de là ils viennent
d'ailleurs
Donc voilà le genre de stockage qu'on a et puis une fois que ces trucs là sont refermées on met un gros tas de terre
par dessus et on en parle plus
alors je vous présente
Qui baigne dans la manche
Sûrement pas au titre des activités actuelles
Il ya eu des déchets immergé en mer je sais plus exactement les mêmes mais ça fait très chaud au moins 40 ans s'est arrêtée
Là je vous présente le plus vieux site de stockage de déchets au monde
Quel âge at il
Il a deux milliards d'années absolument
vous avez ici
lamido clos au gabon
dans laquelle a fonctionné
naturellement donc les hommes n'ont même pas inventé ça où il est brillant ingénieur des mines n'ont même pas inventé l'énergie nucléaire c'est ballot
l'énergie nucléaire a été inventé tout seul par la nature il ya deux milliards d'années
dans la mine dauphin dans des réacteurs naturelles dont vous en avez eu un exemplaire dans cette mine d'uranium
alors je vous la fais très rapide
il ya deux milliards d'années comme la double vie de l'uranium 235 ses 7 à 800 millions d'années
la teneur en uranium
235 dans l'uranium naturel ces trois et demi pour cent ça tombe bien c'est comme dans les réacteurs dans l'uranium enrichi aujourd'hui
et dans cette mine vous avez les infiltrations d'eau dont vous avez le modérateur qui arrivent spontanément par dessus
donc vous avez de l'uranium enrichi le modérateur craque la réaction de fission se met en route
évidemment il faut que la réaction de fission s'est mise en route ça chauffe
du coup ça valorise l'eau du coup il ya plus de modérateur du coup ça s'arrête du coup leur revient du coup ça repart etc
et donc vous avez un réacteur pulsé comme ça qui a fonctionné pendant des centaines de milliers d'années
qui vient des centaines de milliers d'eric et il a fait des déchets
il a fait des produits de fission dont il a fait des déchets question où sont passés les déchets
à la réponse ils sont restés exactement là où ils ont été créés depuis 2 milliards d'années
alors c'est intéressant envoyés à un site dont on s'est foutu on n'a pas fait de débat national sur les déchets n'est rien
nature a fait les choses n'importe comment le foot us à porte ou là comme dans votre chambre c'est dégueulasse
et il s'est rien passé de spécial c'est à dire que les déchets sont restés très exactement à l'endroit où ils ont été créés
Alors heureusement les déchets concret nous ils vont pas attendre 2 milliards d'années vous voyez ici la vitesse de décroissance radioactive
des divers types de produits que nous avons en sortie de réacteur est en fait les déchets de fission comme ils crachent énormément de radioactivité
par contrecoup lors 2010 n'est pas extrêmement élevé vous voyez
là vous avez la radio occidentale l'activité de l'uranium initial qui se manipule à mains nues et voyez que les produits de fission
ils vont pas du récent bilan au bout de quelques siècles
ils sont devenus inoffensifs
Ce qui va durer longtemps c'est plutonium et le plutonium ici on recycle et les actinides mineurs donc en fait le deuxième
en jeu on va dire si on veut vraiment être totalement débarrassée de tous les emmerdements
mais bon c'est pas un gros emmerdements ça m'est totalement débarrassé tous les emmerdements c'est de faire des réacteurs de génération
4 dans lesquelles ça et ça ça brûle dans le réacteur et donc on sort pas ce genre de truc créateurs
on ne sort que ça et ça ça va durer quelques siècles ce qui est pas
ce qui n'est quand même pas un problème majeur puisque le pont du gard est beaucoup plus vieux
Par ailleurs très rapidement tous les êtres vivants sont exposées à la radioactivité
depuis qu'il ya de la vie sur terre
alors est ce que vous savez quel est l'élément qui va le plus agressés
vos cellules
et qui va briser l'adn de chacune de vos cellules j'insiste chacune de vos cellules des centaines de fois par jour
Pas le soleil non
Un truc qui vous rendent par les narines plusieurs fois par minute l'oxygène
l'oxygène est un occident vous rappeler de ça
et donc comme l'oxygène et un occident
ça vous fait des radicaux libres qui se baladent dans votre corps et qui vont vous briser
vos brindas
dn2 chaque cellule des centaines de fois par jour
et ça vous empêche pas de rester vivant
ça vous empêche pas de rester vivant parce que comme l'a dit est apparue sur terre dans un monde hostile soumis aux bombardements
cosmique aux rayonnements ultraviolets du soleil etc
l'adn
plusieurs dizaines de pourcents du codage de l'adn en fait c'est de ces du codage d'auto réparation de l'adn
donc l'adn des centaines de fois par jour aussi s'auto répare
en deux temps en temps le truc part en vrille et à ce moment vous avez un tueur
voilà mais même quand vous avez une tumeur l'essentiel du temps c'est une tumeur bénigne
ou bien la cellule meurt un phénomène qui s'appelle la pop de rezé la cellule meurt donc vous avez pas
Dans le monde des vivants il faut pas croire que
les cellules sont sans défense face aux agressions en fait elles ont une panoplie de défendre la
radioactivité s'il ya des trucs qui peut agresser l'adn mais c'est pas le seul loin s'en faut
donc tous les êtres vivants sont soumis aux rayonnements ionisants ils sont pas tous également
vulnérable aux rayonnements ionisants comme vous pouvez voir ici j'ai pas le temps d'entrer dans le détail
les hommes sont exposés à de la radioactivité
ils sont exposés à la radioactivité naturelle à cause du bombardement cosmique d'accord donc le rayonnement cosmique
c'est la radioactivité naturelle à cause de la radioactivité naturelle des roches et c'est
à cause du radon et c est à cause
la première source pour vous vraisemblablement c'est les expositions médicales enfin pour les populations occidentales c'est des expositions médicales dans vous passer un scanner
vous passer une radio des poumons est ce que je ne souhaite à aucune des femmes dans cette salle malheureusement les statistiques sont contre vous
si un jour vous fait traiter un cancer du poumon je peux vous assurer qu'on vous irradiera copieusement
mais en l'occurrence pour vous sauver la vie en tout cas c'est ce que pense le médecin et il n'a pas tort
donc mais c'est voilà donc les l'irradiation la première source des radiations de très loin celle irradiation d'origine médicale
Alors petite photo choc est-ce que ça c'est tchernobyl
C'est bien la réponse est non
ça c'est du rachitisme
conjuguée à une déficience en fluor alors je vous le montre pour choquer un tout petit peu par l'image
parce qu'il n'ya rien de plus facile que de détourner une image
je peux vous assurer que je prends n'importe quel journaliste de france 3 et je lui dis ça c'est tchernobyl
il le passe directe au 20h
très très facile
rien de plus facile
Je les ai déjà vus donc c'est pour ça que je vous dis
voilà donc ce n'est pas parce qu'il ya quelque chose qui va de travers que c'est nécessairement tchernobyl alors revenons aux conséquences radiologiques
du nucléaire et par exemple aux retombées de tchernobyl
Dans la population qui a suivi les retombées de tchernobyl vous avez de toute façon des gens qui meurent
vous avez de toute façon des gens qui meurent de cancer il y avait des gens qui meurent de cancer avant tchernobyl
donc pour savoir si tchernobyl ou sous toute autre exposition aux rayonnements ionisants
provoque un surplus d'une pathologie quelconque
il faut faire ce qu'on appelle des études de cohorte
c'est exactement comme ça qu'on procède pour le tabac donc pour savoir que le tabac c'est mauvais
on prend dix mille personnes qui fument et 10000 personnes qui sont décomposées exactement de la même manière
par sexe par h par lieu de résidence par habitudes alimentaires etc
toutes égales sauf qu'ils fument pas et puis on regarde au cours du temps comment est-ce que les deux comportent et si ceux qui fument
manifestement ont plus d'un certain nombre de maires devant au cours du temps des maladies cardiovasculaires des cancers etc
que ceux qui fument pas on dit c'est la faute au tabac
et donc c'est comme ça qu'on sait que le tabac provoque plus d'accidents cardiovasculaires première source de surmortalité due au tabac
des cancers du poumon mais pas que les cancers de la vessie par exemple augmentent
avec le tabac donc vous avez un certain nombre de trucs et on sait que c'est ça
avec ce qu'on appelle les études de cohorte est bien pour le nucléaire on procède exactement
de la même manière c'est à dire que vous faites des cohortes et vous regarder des gens qui ont été exposés avec des gens qui
n'ont pas été la difficulté avec les gens avec le nucléaire
c'est que le tabac vous savez combien les gens fument
ils vont chez le tabagisme va chez le buraliste et ils achètent des paquets de cigarettes
pour la radioactivité
poussan fasse que vous ayez un dosimètre sur vous
vous ne savez pas combien vous êtes exposés à la radioactivité donc la difficulté supplémentaire c'est qu'il faut reconstituer cette exposition à la radioactivité
pour savoir quels sont ses conséquences possibles dans la population vous avez sélectionné
d'accord quand vous ne savez pas ça vous ne pouvez pas tirer de conclusions
alors les conclusions qui ont été tirées des études épidémiologiques
elles vous disent en gros deux choses pour aller très vite aux résultats
en deçà leur pardon il ya aussi un truc qu'il faut avoir mais je suis désolé j'ai pas le temps de vous le définir façon
même si j'avais le temps vous comprendriez rien parce que moi non plus vous avez une unité
qui est essentiel non quand je dis moi non plus c'est pas tout à fait vrai
une unité qui est essentielle en ce qui concerne l'impact des rayonnements ionisants qui s'appelle le cid verte et sont
sous multiples qui est 2006 date donc vous avez peut-être déjà vu ce truc là
svm svm
alors soit dit en passant je ne pense pas qu'il y ait un
anti nucléaire vous parlant de millisieverts qu'ils sachent définir ce que c'est qu'un millisieverts parce que la définition fait cinq pages ou à peu près
le millisievert tête une unité dérivé du grès
le grès est une unité d'énergie transférés par le rayonnement à la matière et qui vaut un joule parking poids
d'accord donc quand vous avez reçu un gré
c'est que le rayonnement vous a transféré un joule par kilo de poids une irradiation du cancer du sein typique c'est 50 gré
50 jours par kilo poids sur trois mois
envoyez c'est pas une très grande unité
Le milicien le si verte c'est un grès fois un facteur
multiplicatif qui dépend du type de rayonnement donc le facteur multiplicatif ses 20 pour les neutrons mais j'ai pas quoi eu un pour le bêta
qui dépend du type d'organes considérer
qui dépend du fait que c'est une exposition externe ou interne enfin par exemple htc l'encyclopédie votre truc
mais c'est ça l'unité de doses reçues qu'on utilise quand on parle de la dangerosité des rayonnements ionisants
alors avec cette unité là
en dessous de 100 millisieverts par an on ne voit rien
si vous faites des études épidémiologiques
et que vous comparez des gens qui reçoivent 80 et des gens qui reçoivent 10 vous voyez pas de différence
c'est pour ça que thomas pesquet prend le risque d'aller en prendre 180 dans l'espace
en se disant normalement ça me fera rien il a bien raison et c'est pour ça que les hôtesses d'easyjet en prennent dix dans l'année
en se disant ça me fera rien elles ont bien
Au dessus de 100 200 plus exactement vous commencez à voir apparaître des effets qui sont proportionnels à la dose reçue
encore donc si vous avez une population qui est exposé à 400 millisieverts tu
de tels types de rayonnements eh bien ça vous fera toutes choses égales par ailleurs
50% dès que des faits en plus que si vous avez reçu 300 en supposant qu à partir de 2 à 2,5 à rien
C'est ça le
sait c'est ça l'idée
ça c'est les données d'observation
alors pour les conséquences de tchernobyl
première chose il faut reconstituer l'exposition reçues
et le rayonnement reçue et comme les gens n'avaient pas de dosimètre sur eux
ça veut dire vous devez avoir un modèle qui vous reconstitue la circulation atmosphérique
la demi vie des isotopes etc pour imaginer qui a été exposé à quoi enfin pour modéliser plus exactement pas imaginer
modéliser qui a été exposé à quoi
ça déjà c'est un truc avec des incertitudes
Ensuite
vous n'avez vous avez un certain nombre de pathologies
qui existait avant tchernobyl ici par exemple vous avez l'incidence des cancers à la thyroïde dans la population française et tchernobyl et la
Question est-ce que vous pensez que ça a eu un effet discernable
Alors les gens une partie des gens peuvent dire bah oui ça monte ça monte pis là ça aurait dû s'arrêter
Une autre partie des gens vous disent non non il n'ya pas n'y a pas en fait ce qu'ils font c'est la dérive et la
dérive et n'a pas changé
et alors en fait c'est le deuxième qui ont raison
il se trouve que l'on trouve plus de cancers de la thyroïde à cavan pour plein de raisons d'abord parce qu'on la cherche
certes avant vous aviez des tas de gens y mourrait on n'allait pas leur ouvrir la thyroïde donc savais pas qu'il y avait des modules
Ensuite la détection paris la détection des
nodules
s'améliore parce que l'imagerie devient plus précise est donc aujourd'hui vous détectez des trucs 1 mm alors qu'avant voulait détecté à 1 cm
mais c'est toujours compté comme une détection
Donc vous avez tout un tas de trucs et puis vous avez vraiment
une augmentation de l'incidence qui est dû facteurs environnementaux
qu'on ne connaît pas nécessairement mais pas ça
dernier point il faut savoir qu'à tchernobyl il ya eu une augmentation
de l'incidence des cancers à la thyroïde chez les enfants au moment de l'accident mais pas chez les adultes
Parce que quand vous êtes enfant
votre thyroïde est en train de se construire pour vous absorbez de l'yonne en quantité plus importante que quand vous êtes adulte
donc en fait la radioprotection à base de diodes non à
base pour saturer la thyroïde diotte vous savez si jamais il ya un accident alors vous donne des pastilles diodes
en fait chez les adultes ça sert à rien ça sert chez les enfants mais c'est pas chez les adultes
Je veux un cran plus loin vous avez tous évidemment puisque vous êtes venu à ce cours sauf un an pardon je vous taquine
sur le changement climatique
vous avez donc tous entendu parler du giec ipcc en anglais
le giec est une instance onusienne qui a été créée sous la double tutelle de l'union
pendant 2 du programme des nations unies pour l'environnement
et de l'organisation météorologique mondiale et dont le mandat est de faire une compilation de la littérature scientifique disponible
sur l'impact de l'homme sur le climat
eh bien il se trouve qu'en
il ya eu une grande soeur ou un grand frère je ne sais pas du giec qui a été créé avec le même par an
pour tous à gauche donc le programme des nations unies pour l'environnement et un autre par an pour tous à droite
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
et le mandat du giec est très exactement le même que celui du
de l'unhcr pardon est très exactement le même que celui du giec mais dans un autre domaine
l'unhcr a pour mandat de faire une compilation de la littérature scientifique disponible sur l'impact des rayonnements ionisants sur les êtres humains
dans un autre domaine
parce qu'on sait depuis un siècle depuis que marie curie en est morte que la radioactivité à haute dose c'est pas bon
et alors voilà le rapport de lune ce qui est art sur fukushima a sorti en 2013
et c'est la phrase qui est en rouge que je vous laisse lire parce que vous êtes tous des anglicistes distinguer
et vous voyez la conclusion des études
publiées dans la littérature scientifique
en l'occurrence les revues médicales c'est qu'il n'y a pas de conséquence radiologique sur les hommes
venant de l'accident de fukushima n'a pas encore fait la reconstitution des expositions
conjugué à ce qu'on sait sur les seuils à partir desquels dangereux d'être exposés
font que on sait les capable de dire qui aura pas de conséquences radiologiques
il ya des conséquences à l'évacuation de la population parce que ça crée du stress des gens qui se mettent à fumer et à boire
etc et à celui-ci des sens est par contre et même ça c'est pas complètement clair soit dit en passant mais
mais on sait que ça a des conséquences est absolument certain par contre strictement radiologiques
l'autorité de sûreté canadienne après fukushima
j'ai accéléré parce qu'il est quasiment 80 a décidé de restreindre le périmètre d'évacuation autour des centrales
Justement sur la base de sa en dix ans les morts que je vais créer en stressant les gens en les évacuant
c'est plus en espérance mathématiques que ce que je vais peut-être évité
à cause des retombées radiologique donc jeu restreint le périmètre d'évacuation
Ici vous avez un
graff qui a été fait qui a été publié aussi dans une revue médicale
et qui vous donne
les morts par térawattheures en ce qui concerne les diverses sources de production électrique est ce que vous voyez c'est que le nucléaire
accident compris est le mieux placé
parce que
le charbon c'est 30 morts par térawattheures parce que maladies pulmonaires des mineurs de charbon
parce que morts par accidents dans les mines et parce que pollution alors ben
d'accord donc si vous mettez tous un bout-à-bout et bien ça vous fait 30 morts par térawattheures etc et voyez que le nucléaire est médicalement
celle qui présente le moins de risques
après faut vraiment que j'accélère
Donc si vous n'êtes pas trop pressés à la fin du cours je vous propose de venir poser la question
dans les deux minutes là encore et puis
Après vous avez un
sujet évidemment qui est le sujet de la bombe alors sujet de la bombe
il ya
deux facteurs qui poussent dans le sens de quand on a du nucléaire civil c'est plus facile d'avoir la bombe
le premier c'est évidemment le corpus commun de compétences
sur un physicien nucléaire qui sait ce que c'est qu'une fiction et bien il n'est pas très loin d'un physicien nucléaire qui sait ce que
c'est qu'une fiction dans une bombe
cela étant sur le plan technologique par contre c'est quand même des technologies qui sont assez distinctes heureusement
est par ailleurs comme je l'expliquais tout à l'heure la filière
d'enrichissement du combustible
est une filière qui est potentiellement
proliférante puisqu'il suffit de rajouter des étages et vous passez de l'uranium qui sert dans une centrale à l'uranium qui sert dans une bombe
1 235
alors après il se trouve que en fait les données d'observation
Sur ce qui s'est passé dans le monde vous montre qu' il ya énormément de pays
qui ont eu la bombe qui n'ont jamais eu la moindre centrale
Israël par exemple
Fait partie de ces de ces pays là
l'afrique du sud a eu du potentiel donc vous avez un certain nombre de pays qui ont soit eu la bombe ayant renoncé soit
l'on le disparaît
et c'est mai et qui n'ont que j'avais eu la moindre centrale
enfin en tout cas qui au moment où ils ont mis la bombe n'avait pas la main de centrales
soit dit en passant c'est aussi le cas des états unis et de la russie au moment où ils ont eu accès à l'armé atomique
donc ce que vous dit l'histoire c'est qu'en fait la bombe
vient avant tout de l envie de la voir et pas avant tout du fait d'avoir des centrales civiles
C'est pas le premier déterminant le premier déterminant c'est vous ayez envie d'avoir
Inversement le fait que vous ayez des centrales civiles si vous décidez de des commissions des bombes
il faut que vous sachiez quoi faire de l'uranium qui a dans les bombes et du plutonium qui a dans les bombes
et un truc qui est très bien pour être sûr que vous ayez plus la bombe ces deux le cramé dans une centrale du caire
enfin bien sûr que vous l'avez plus si vous dites je le mets dans un coin et puis je vous garantie gie toucherait pas
va vous pouvez éventuellement vous dire que c'est fait une promesse d'ivrogne
alors que si vous le mettez pas dans un coin mais dans une centrale et vous le brûler là vous êtes sûr on y touche
lui a plu
voilà donc c
c'est plus compliqué qu'il n'y paraît cette histoire entre entre civils
et militaires
Alors je vais accélérer parce que ça je vous en ai déjà parlé la génération 4 je vous en ai parlé rapidement aussi donc j'accélère
alors la question pour finir ce truc là
c'est si on veut que le nucléaire y tiennent là dans le haut du graphique c'est à dire qu'il soit un contributeur très
significatif à la décarbonation d'une société qui ne renoncerait pas à son confort
d'accord c'est ça la question à laquelle en arrive eh bien il faut qu'il soit capable de faire du puy 5 à 10% par an
et là évidemment on tombe sur un certain nombre de questions
Par exemple le
Savent on s'en fout parce que je les ai déjà parlé c'est plutôt ça
La question c'est est-ce qu'on a la possibilité
de faire en quelques dizaines d'années
un parc de quelques aller de quelques milliers de réacteurs sachant qu'on en a aujourd'hui 450 dans le monde voilà ça la question
donc est ce qu on a l'argent
parce que comme je le disais tout à l'heure il faut de l'argent alors l'argent il y en a il y en a plein
la question c est ce qu on a l'argent qu'ils acceptent d'aller s'investir là dedans c'est plutôt ça la question
donc est ce qu on a soit des états qui dit c'est comme ça et on discute pas ce qui est le cas de la
chine
soit un monde privé qui dit j'en est vachement envie parce que tout bien pesé c'est beaucoup moins risqué plus reste
est à ce moment qu il le fait
pour le moment vous l'avez pas c'est plutôt l'inversé
L'europe par exemple considère que le nucléaire c'est pas vers
donc en ce moment il ya une réglementation qui est en train de se mettre en place à la commission européenne
sur ce qu'on appelle les investissements verts dans la finance et le nucléaire est explicitement exclue comme étant un truc pas vers
ce qui est de mon point de vue est une erreur mais je ne suis qu'un d'électeurs parmi 400 millions d'européens
Autre question est y aura les compétences
parce que dans beaucoup de sujets si on veut changer de système de bout en bout
il faut qu'ils les gens qui sont capables de faire
Ensuite
est-ce qu'on saura si prendre suffisamment à l avance parce que le centrale nucléaire ça se construit quand même un peu moins vite
qu'une fuite en paille
donc une fois qu'on a décidé de le faire c'est pas la semaine d'après gaussens pas le sort de terre
Voilà est-ce qu'on sait où les maîtres alors ça en l'occurrence oui parce qu'on peut les mettre à la place des centrales à charbon
Voilà donc le
la fin quantitative de cet exposé
c'est que
pendant et je vais finir avec un élément que je vous ai pas projeter leur âme et qui vient du dernier rapport 1.5 du giec
dans le rapport 1.5 du giec
tous les scénarios d'émissions qui permettent de rester sous la barre des 1 degré et demi
sont des scénarios qui voit un nucléaire x 2 à 6
D'ici à 2100 je crois de mémoire
donc c'est tous des scénarios dans lesquels le nucléaire se développe
évidemment il n'y a pas que ça qui se développe il ya aussi les énergies renouvelables et les économies d'énergie
Mais
voilà donc pour pour finir cet exposé
quand on regarde pour vous donner une conclusion un peu personnel quand on regarde les avantages et les inconvénients
donc les avantages du nucléaire et ses risques
un monde qui renonce au nucléaire est paradoxalement un monde qui acceptent de courir plus de risques
qu'un monde qui souhaite en faire plus
encore en termes d'arbitrages des risques parce que si vous en faites -
ou bien vous augmentez l'envi de recourir à des modes fossiles
Qui sont potentiellement porteur de risques on a vu au moment du cours sur le changement climatique
qui sont à des échelles qui n'ont strictement rien à voir
Ou bien
vous prenez le pari qu'on va y arriver juste avec des renouvelables moderne dont on parlera aux prochains cours et vous verrez que c'est un
pari dont je ne suis pas complètement sûr qu'il peut réussir comme ça
compte tenu des éléments on va voir
Ou bien vous
prenez de paris pardon
que la société va être capable de résister à une contraction rapide de son approvisionnement énergétique
puisque vous ne faites ni fossiles ni nucléaire avec les renouvelables sont pas suffisantes
tout en restant stables compte tenu de ce qu'on a vu au premier cours sur le lien entre l'activité
productive et l'énergie quand donc vous avez un arbitrage entre ces trois risques il n'y a pas de repas gratuits dans cette histoire
il ya un arbitrage entre ces trois risques et ma conclusion personnelle que je serai à partager
c'est que dans cet arbitrage entre ces trois risques
c'est très paradoxal de dire ça en france mais plus on fait de nucléaire et moins encore de risque voilà en gros
ça n'exclut pas du tout le fait qu'il faut faire énormément d'économie d'énergie
et qu'il y aura plein de renouvelables intéressante dans un certain nombre de cas de figure mais globalement c'est ça ma conclusion
voilà je suivrai encore une fois vraiment désolé d'avoir zappé le
leur correcte de début on a réussi à faire tenir l'essentiel dans le temps qui restait voilà oui
C'est à dire
à
alors aujourd'hui la politique française est une politique et j'espère que je ne vais choquer
obtient d'anciennes élèves de ginette dans cette salle mais c'est une politique mensuellement jésuites
c'est à dire que
c'est une politique qui consiste à dire
j'en fais tout et n'ayant d'en faire tout en trouvant quand même c'est pas mal d'en faire et que je veux dire que je vais
en faire un peu plus d'un côté tout en disant je vais en faire un peu moins de l'autre non mais c'est exactement ça en
france
donc c'est le genre de truc
que vous sort votre grain quand vous l'avez pris la main dans le pot de confiture et qu'ils essayent de vous expliquer que non non
il n'y avait pas du tout c'est exactement ça la position du pouvoir français en ce moment
alors du côté plus
on a demandé à edf de commencer à regarder où elle allait construire de nouvelles centrales
donc on a mis en route une simple la construction d'une centrale à flamanville
qu'on a mise en route avant les 2 op r qu'on a commencé à construire à taishan en chine
qu'on terminera après
si la série golo parce que plus la centrale a été commencé tôt plus elle sera terminée tard
donc alors c'est pas tout à fait vrai pas tout à fait faux parce que
pas tout à fait vrai parce que olkiluoto en finlande sera probablement lancée avant flamanville quand même mais bon peu importe
Les règles ne sont pas tout à fait les mêmes
je vais vous donner un exemple alors il est caricatural mais c'est que pour vous comprenez bien en
france vous avez un couvercle de cuve que vous laissez tomber par terre
l'asn vous dit vous leur faites en chine vous laissez tomber le congrès de cus par peut porter je tiens ça de
dirigeants de framatome les chinois le passé aux rayons x test à l'hélium vache un autre qui dit ça va bien je m'installe
donc c'est voilà donc c'est pas du tout
maintenant mais
les deux se défendre
Chinois ont un très bon passeur qui court beaucoup plus de risques
Donc
donc là on a on a dit à et df
fait des nouvelles centrales
mais dans le même temps on lui dit fait descendre enfin on va descendre la part du nucléaire à 50%
On dit également
cette descente à 50% est destiné à avoir moins de réacteurs sauf que je sais pas si j'aurai le temps que vous montrez la prochaine
fois mais il ya une page sur mon site perso qui dissertent là dessus qu'ils s'appellent 50 % ou 50 % pour ceux qui ont
envie d'aller voir donc j'explique que l'observation du quart allemand et le cas espagnol
fait que moi si j'ai mon propre argent à parier je suis prêt à le faire
50% de nucléaire ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ferme un réacteur sur trois
ça veut dire qu'on va baisser de 30% le facteur de charge de l'ensemble du parc nucléaire
Parce que une
nuit d'hiver sans vent vous accepterez pas que les trains n'avance pas que le laminoir fonctionne pas que l'enfant à 19 heures un soir d'hiver
que l'ascenseur n'arrive pas que vous soyez dans noir et que votre cuisinière marche pas il acceptera y passa
et donc on va garder les centrales nucléaires en sécurité et on les fait fonctionner quand ya pas de vent et pas de soleil on
sait exactement ce qu'ont fait les allemands les allemands ont la même puissance électrique pilotable aujourd'hui qu'il avait il ya 17 ans quand même
100 gigawatts sauf que le facteur de charge a baissé d'1 5% ou plus peine 30%
alors qu'est ce qui se passe si vous faites baisser de facteurs de charge d'un système à coûts fixes vous faites baisser ses recettes
alors que les coûts sont les mêmes donc en fait vous allez augmenter le risque nucléaire
donc le programme français et un truc qui est destiné à augmenter le risque nucléaire
c'est ça ma conclusion
tout en vous disant que c'est l'inversé
On dit en france c'est caca berck mais quand même si on pouvait avoir des succès à l'exportation ça serait quand même vachement bien
donc chez nous on va fermer fessenheim est quand même si on pouvait en furie au coréen
appelant coréen à abou dhabi ça se passe bien et puis
quand même le fait que les finlandais y prennent le deuxième réacteur chéreau satom alors que nous on est vachement bien alors fournir quand même
c'est des gens pas sympa bon d'accord ils tueront de foot quoi maintenant
Le
Latitude française aujourd'hui sur le nucléaire
et le truc le plus ambivalent qui soit et le plus comment
Nous
Te place un jour à gauche un jour à droite un jour à gauche un joueur à droite
Etc et c'est le reflet notamment
d'une opinion qui elle-même est un peu hésitante site comprend pas bien etc voilà
les anglais ont une attitude beaucoup plus cash sur le nucléaire et le disent nous on n'en veut
si les français vous n'êtes pas capables d'en faire on envoie aux chinois
les russes en sont pleins et du reste le carnet de commandes de rosatom il ya 30 réacteurs
dedans et on sait même pas comment ils vont faire pour les construire tellement rien non
puis continuer à engranger encore plein les chinois ils doivent voir 20 réacteurs en construction
j'avais fait une intervention pour liane sdn il ya quelques années dans laquelle j'avais dit en conclusion
je suis absolument certain qui aura duré du nucléaire dans 30 ans si d'ici là on n'a pas une météorite qui nous est tombé dessus
ou la guerre thermonucléaire ou un virus qui ne va éradiquer
je suis certain la seule question est de savoir s'il sera chinois en chine chinois en france aux français en france
mais sinon je suis sûr qu'il en aura 6 il ya toujours quoi que ce soit qui ressemble à une humanité
à peu près industriel
absolument certain
du coup on prend du retard
parce que quand vous avez un actionnaire qui arrête pas de dire à sa filiale ce que tu fais c'est pas terrible mais fellow quand
même mais quand même c'est pas terrible et puis je veux dire publiquement que c'est pas terrible mais quand même fait le camp même
Temps le vent commence à se retourner un tout petit peu dans l'opinion
Je rencontre de plus en plus de gens qui étaient
classiquement
prédestiné à être anti nucléaire si vous me pardonnez cette façon caricaturale d'étiqueter les gens
plutôt du bobo de gauche bien pensants
qui se met à me dire mais c'est complètement stupide de fermer des réacteurs nucléaires
Ont donc des gens inattendu j'ai envie de dire qui voit là c'est intéressant de constater que on commence à en voir quelques uns
Dépanner et pas nécessairement des mois oui
Eh bien je voulais dit je ne sais pas
Il ya la question est
pourquoi est-ce que le nucléaire fait partie de ces quelques sujets n'y en a pas tant que ça mais de ces quelques sujets où
la compréhension de la population sur les dangers
et raisonnablement orthogonale à la réalité des dangers vous avez un certain nombre de dangers environnementaux sur lesquels
les gens peuvent avoir une idée un peu exagéré ou au contraire
Pas assez présente quelque part
sous-estimer les 8 mai quand même comprendre que entre guillemets ça pue
par exemple sur la question des changements climatiques
les gens n'ont pas nécessairement en tête la réalité des risques mais comprend bien que c'est un truc emmerdant
sur les phytosanitaires
les gens ont pas en tête la réalité des risques mais ils comprennent bien qu'un truc qui est bazarder dans la nature pour tuer des
êtres vivants en l'occurrence des insectes ou des herbes
Il ya un moment où ça doit pas être terrible pour nous d'accord donc il faut aller regarder d'un peu près c'est une question de
dose de machin truc etc mais que quand même on peut se poser la question
Toujours sur la pêche par exemple
il ya des gens qui peuvent se dire oui effectivement on voit les stocks de poissons baissé il va bien se passer quelque chose
il ya quelques sujets environnementaux pas tant mais quelques-uns
lee nucléaire en faisant partie où il ya en france
j'insiste sur le fait que ces français parce que c'est pas vrai dans tous les pays du monde un écart assez significatif
entre les faits documentés par la littérature scientifique
papa la technologie de la littérature scientifique au sens de j'observe le monde et l'opinion qu'on peut en avoir
quelques hypothèses c'est des hypothèses donc faut vraiment les prendre comme tel de différence entre les deux
la première c'est que
dans la presse
l'anti nuclear isme si vous l'observez bien est essentiellement le fait des médias de service public qui se considèrent comme tels
jan aps le monde se considère comme un média de service public
Quand vous êtes dans un médiateur alors l'hypothèse que je fais j'aime bien c'est une hypothèse
c'est que quand vous êtes dans un média vous voulez montrer vous êtes indépendant
j'organiserai qu'il est indépendant qui est à la botte de personnes et si c'est l'état qui vous paye
la meilleure manière de montrer que vous n'êtes pas à la botte de l'état c'est à dire du mal de ce que fait l'état
donc si vous êtes journaliste de service public et ça par contre c'est aussi un truc que vous allez pouvoir marquer vous allez dire
préférentiellement du mal de la police de la façon dont on organise le système d'enseignement
de la façon dont fonctionne l'hôpital
de la sncf etc et à ce moment je pense que le nucléaire passe tout simplement dans ce grand ensemble
comme c'est un truc que fait l'état craque ça passe dans tous les trucs que l'état fait de travers
Et vous pouvez vous pouvez remarquer que quand vous avez une émission jeu pourquoi
complémente enquête investigations spéciales etc sur france 2 ou sur france 3 ça n'est que de l'instruction à charge
donc on va pas vous amener un médecin vous avez vu montrer que c'était les médecins
qui détenait les clefs de lecture sur est-ce que c'est dangereux ou pas pour la santé j'en ferai jamais un
c'est les ingénieurs que ça vous dire comment fonctionne un réacteur vous en verrez jamais un
c'est les physiciens qui ça vous expliquer ce que c'est que le nucléaire vous en verrez jamais un vous verrez les militants antinucléaires
toujours les mêmes
C'est un parti pris de la presse et je vous dis que j'ai une explication putative mais ça ne salent reste une hypothèse
Après il ya également un deuxième truc qui à mon avis pèse en france c'est le tandem franco allemand
la france considère depuis très longtemps que le socle fondateur de l'europe c'est le couple franco allemand
alors il ya des tas de bonnes raisons de penser que c'est vrai mais il se trouve que les allemands eux
le nucléaire est un sujet qui est historiquement beaucoup plus affectif que en france
ils ont eu deux fusées pershing sur leur sol est un traumatisme
ça rappelle la seconde guerre mondiale enfin bon
c'est plein de trucs qui sont assimilés affection associée a dépensé beaucoup plus affectif que pour nous français
est donc dans le couple franco allemand
il ya eu
en gros ces allemands qui font tous bien ils ont une économie qui tient la route une barrière industrie etc
par ailleurs il aime pas le nucléaire
les jeux c'est pareil c'est une hypothèse mais je me dis c'est un peut-être joué un rôle
le fait que la france s'est progressivement écartés d'une industrie nucléaire bon au début elle a été extrêmement fier je veux dire par les années
70-80 la population accuse alors aujourd'hui même la population vous avez 50 % de prod tiède
30% d'anti tiède et 15 % de gens qui vous disent qu'ils savent pas si vous regardez dans le dans la manière dont les gens
disent il importe donc cessé un
Essai j'ai pas fini mon étude de cas sociologique pour savoir pourquoi la situation se présente comme ça dans notre pays c'est ça reste un
truc ça reste pas à mystères non résolus mais ça reste une question partiellement non résolus
Oui après il ya une question fond
Au siège qui vous fait en fermant commune ps verts ça va aller bah du coup je pensais que j'avais pas le temps
Alors la fusion est ce que ça marche
alors si ça marche oui le problème c'est que comme réacteurs industriel ça marchera pas avant vous soyez morts
alors je vous la fait courte mais bonne aujourd'hui on est en train de construire terre
iter alors la fusion c'est quoi ces vous mettez la matière sous forme de plasma vous savez tous que c'est qu'un plasma
donc un plasma ces quelques millions de degrés est pour porter la matière à quelques millions de degrés pour la chauffer
donc vous avez un investissement initial en énergie pour porter la matière à quelques millions de degrés
iter par ailleurs une fois que la matière et à quelques millions de degrés c'est compliqué de mettre ça dans une boîte en plastique
alors ça ne tiendrait pas bien donc il faut donc la seule manière que vous avez de confiner ça c'est dans un champ magnétique
et ça tombe bien c'est une matière ionisée
d'un champ magnétique
donc en fait le principe de la fusion si vous faites un champ magnétique
pour confiner la matière en fusion sous forme de tore
et déclencher le plasma sous forme de tore est déclenchée dans ce plasma une réaction de fusion
Le
Iter est un est quelque chose qui est destiné à vérifier est un engin qui est destiné à valider
expérimentalement la possibilité de retirer un peu plus
d'énergie de fusion que l'énergie que vous avez utilisé pour mettre le placement en chauffe
donc avec iter on sera content si on fait de la fusion sur quelques minutes
actuellement dans les tokamaks vous êtes plutôt à quelques secondes avant tout c'est un gros tokamak donc faut encore dix ans pour qu'on sourit terre
premier plasma 2025 est annoncée vous faites fonctionner 10 en 2035
après vous vous grattez la tête pendant cinq ans pour savoir ce que vous allez faire derrière 2040
puis vous commencez à construire le truc qui est derrière éventuellement un
prototype de réacteur de fusion c'est à dire un truc où la fusion du repas deux minutes mais 5000 heures parce que dans les réacteurs
nucléaires actuelles la réaction du rpt 5000 heures
alors voir elle dure trois ans dans vingt-quatre mille heures sans s'arrêter
vous pouvez pas faire un réacteur industriels pour servir la population en électricité avec un stock qui font des marais côtiers dix minutes
moi je vois bien
donc il faut faire le truc d'après don jeudi 2025 2035 2040 on décide de construire un démonstrateur de réacteurs industrielle de fusion
en 2000 55 60 il est prêt
en 2070 il a fonctionné 10 ans
et en 2075 vous commencez à construire une tête de série
qui sera donc terminée d'être construite en 2090 ou 2095 et à vous serez mort
Depuis longtemps donc
donc la fusion
avec les échéances que je vous ai montré à la fois sur le changement climatique et sur la
question d'approvisionnement en combustibles fossiles dans les zones qui commence à être un peu contrainte notamment l'europe
vous oubliez ça fait pas partie des moyens du bord
Et toujours pour rester dans le politiquement incorrect
je fais partie des gens extrêmement pro nucléaires qui n'auraient jamais mis un centime dans iter
car s'il en avait dépendu que moi on n'aurait jamais fait
on aura mis cet argent dans un programme de quatrième génération accéléré dans la fission
jamais débouché par une amie questions vont
Oui
Alors comme disent les américains batibouw questionner quand ils veulent être poli et que leurs intérieures intacte très bonne question
Manière de se mettre les journalistes dans la poche en finale
Alors il faut savoir qu'une centrale nucléaire
c'est
un assemblage de legos donc ce n'est pas un objet monobloc qui a une durée de vie en tant qu'objet monobloc
c'est un
assemblage de legos dans laquelle chaque briques de lego a sa propre durée de vie est en fait le seul briques de lego que vous
ne pouvez pas changer dans une centrale nucléaire une fois que vous l'avez construite c'est la cuve du réacteur
tout le reste vous pouvez le changer et donc un grand paradoxe par exemple c'est que fessenheim
est entre guillemets une des centrales les plus neuves du parc français
parce que comme elle a été construite il ya longtemps il ya longtemps qu'on a changé tout ce qu'on pouvait changer à l'intérieur
on a changé les alternateurs les générateurs de vapeur les machins les groupes électrogènes de secours alors vous n'avez pas tout changer
donc vous changer au cours à l'est et en fait
vous avez donc en fait le constructeur vous dis moi je fais des plans pour que ça dure au moins tant de temps
mais c'est pas quelque chose qui a une du commandeur
la seule pièce pour laquelle ce truc là
tiens ils vont éventuellement quelque chose heureusement c'est la cuve du réacteur
du coup comme tout le reste vous pouvez changer
la manière dont ça se passe c'est que vous avez l'autorité de sûreté
qui vient tous les dix ans regardez le réacteur et vous dire
il est bon pour le service tel qu'il se présente pour les 10 ans qui viennent
quoi que vous fassiez dessus je décide de l'arrêter serge ce truc ne tient plus la route
et dont en particulier la cub j'estime que ces fragilités font qu' elle ne peut pas garantir un fonctionnement sûr pour les années qui viennent
ou bien
un truc intermédiaires qui en france est plus souvent le cas
je vous remercie une dix ans à condition que vous fassiez çà çà çà çà çà et 100 d'accord
vous me changer d'aile machin vous rajoutez tel truc et c'est post fukushima par exemple
l'asn a demandé à edf de mettre toutes ses centrales nucléaires en
conformité avec des normes de sûreté plus élevé par exemple mettre sous le bâtiment réacteur un radier pour et un radier pour
récupérer le corium si jamais le coeur font enfin voilà un certain nombre de trucs
et donc dans le grand carénage que bdf a démarré vous avez une partie des investissements qui sont une augmentation
des normes de sûreté que l'asn a demandé aux réacteurs français
les réacteurs français on avait dit au début on se la donne pour 40 ans
aujourd'hui et des f10 on va les prolonger à 50 ou 60
si on peut
il aussi on peut c'est si l'asn nous donne l'autorisation de le faire dit autrement et df considère que si des scènes de l'autorisation
ça ne fait pas courir de risque de les exploiter à 50 ou 60 ans
aux états unis je vous ai dit qu'il y avait une centaine de réacteurs en fonctionnement
la quasi totalité des 100 sinon la totalité des 100 réacteurs en fonctionnement ont été autorisés pour 60 ans
la quasi totalité
cela est dans la philosophie de l'autorité de sûreté américaine est différente parce que eux
ils considèrent qu'à tout instant le réacteur doit être conforme à ses spécifications de départ
alors qu'en france comme je disais tout à l'heure à tout instant vous devez être conformes aux spécifications du moment
Qui se durcissent avec le temps
Mais donc aux etats-unis ont dit si à tout instant c'est conforme à ce que ça devait faire au moment où vous avez construit le
réacteur bat bien
et donc ils ont tous demandé leur extension à 60 ans et il y aura un certain nombre qui commence à réfléchir à l'extension à
80 et 2 fait tant que vous n'avez pas de défaut sur la cuve
ça ne pose pas le problème de principe
d'accord et pour revenir au pont du gard danse parlais tout à l'heure
tant que pont du gard les pierres ne se fissure pas il peut continuer à servir de pompe
et ça fait 2000 ans qui sert de pont et si ça se trouve il peut encore servir de pont de bilan
Alors qu'il ya longtemps que le pont construit par un constructeur que je ne nommerai pas
relié à un endroit que je ne nommerai pas un autre endroit que je ne devrais pas se casser la gueule
comme le pont jane
Non mais voilà donc c'est c1
La processus
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que en fait cette notion de durée de vie il n'a pas tellement d'intérêt
parce qu'encore une fois ces mots ne sais pas me bloque et que c'est un processus d'évaluation
permanente de l'état de ce que vous avez en face de vous qui est la bonne réponse
Oui
Ils en sont ils en sont au même stade c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui personne n'est capable de vous faire un plasma qui reste en fusion
pendant cinq mineurs
Oui mais ce que je veux dire c'est que
iter par ailleurs il était décidé que ça coûte 30 milliards
d'euros je pense que là on doit être rendu à 50 ou 60 ou 90 après le facteur pis
donc je suis pas complètement sûr que
Admettons qu'on fasse un réacteur de fusion d'ici à ce que vous mourriez ok on change strictement rien à ce que je voulais raconter
Parce que c'est pas la même chose
parce que c'est quand même beaucoup plus simple de faire fissionner en matériaux en laissant le matériau à quelques centaines de degrés
que de porter un plasma quelques millions de degrés
Peut-être juste beaucoup plus simple
Pardon d'eux
a alors davantage c'est que
tout ce que nous pouvons nous le ferons il ya un philosophe qui a dit ça tout ce que nous pouvons nous le ferons
donc quand vous êtes parti dans une filière
à un moment on va créer de la recherche il ya des physiciens qui ont découvert les interactions fortes
donc ils ont commencé à regarder
ce qui se passait à l'intérieur du noyau ils ont compris que sur le papier on pouvait fusionner des protons
et que c'est enfin ou dur et qu'on pourrait fusionner les noyaux et que ça faisait des loyers aux plus lourds ils ont constaté que
c'était ça qui se passait dans le soleil et ils sont ni tiens ça serait rigolo essayer de faire pareil
et donc tout ce que nous pouvons nous ferons
Pour elle ce qu'on fait des taxis volant dans paris
Pour est-ce que la ratp rêve de faire des taxis volant dans paris
parce que tout ce que nous pouvons y serons c'est juste d'abord on fait pas ce canton ça rigolo de faire des trucs nouveaux et
ensuite on se pose la question de savoir si c'était une bonne idée
Pour tous moi je veux dire
Aujourd'hui en l'occurrence
Non mais c'est exactement ça c'est un regard regarder l'histoire des techniques
c'est ça du début à la fin tout ce que nous pouvons au fond
alors oui
Alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait les réacteurs qu'on fait aujourd'hui une bonne question
Il se trouve que par exemple au début des
années 50
les militaires américains avaient envisagé ne veut parler pas ça vous amuse et cette anecdote
les militaires américains avaient envisagé de faire un avion de combat
avec un réacteur à sels fondus
pas du tout la même technologie
parce que c'est des réacteurs qui sont extrêmement réactif
et donc capa vous êtes capable de piloter une puissance de deux manières comme comme une pédale d'accélérateur
alors en fait la raison pour laquelle on est parti sur la technologie qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
d'après ce que j'ai compris bajoues sait il faudrait que je les réussis mais d'après ce que j'ai compris
c'est parce que ses dérivés des premiers réacteurs
qui ont été mis au point pour des raisons militaires qui étaient des réacteurs de propulsion de bâtiments de guerre
marine
en fait les réacteurs qu'on fait aujourd'hui à coeur solide
à l'uranium
sont d'abord la filière uranium on est partis dessus parce que c'est ce qui permet de faire des armes
l'uranium 235 et plutonium alors que la filière thorium non donc ça a été un des critères de choix entre l'uranium et thorium
et ensuite les réacteurs refroidis à aux hackers solide
c'est une technologie avec laquelle vous pouvez faire des réacteurs assez compact que vous pouvez embarquer sur des porte avions des sous marins
et donc c'est la raison pour laquelle on a commencé par développer ses réacteurs là qu'on savait faire qu'une fois qu'on savait faire cela
confère ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure tous que nous savons tous que nous pouvons nous ferons dont on les a faits et ensuite
on s'est dit tiens on peut en faire de l'électricité aussi et donc c'est cette technologie là qu'on a dérivé pour faire de l'électricité
à ce moment là on s'est pas dit on va reprendre la copie à 0 et les réacteurs pour faire de l'électricité on va éventuellement
utiliser une technologie totalement différente
on avait ça dans les cartons et donc c'est ça qu'on a utilisées
Oui
Parce que une fois que vous avez des industriels qui sont installés sur le marché avec une technologie dominante on reste à ça
tant qu'ils sont pas menacés tant qu'on a pas inventé la photo numérique c'est qu'aulas qui dominent le marché
Donc là tant que vous avez des gens qui ont mis au point des technologies qui avait déjà en première
usagers donc ils avaient déjà les brevets il avait déjà les ingénieurs qui savait faire il avait déjà etc
s'il suffit de faire la même chose en plus gros
ben vous avez un avantage concurrentiel terrible par rapport aux gens qui repart de zéro dans leur labo
C'est évident pour que c'est la filière industrielle qui va aller de l'avant
Alors aujourd'hui il ya un certain nombre de gens encore une fois qui se gratte la tête
sait on est un peu en train de rebattre les cartes
mais c'est
il n'empêche que la technologie dominante et pour encore longtemps sur le marché
c'est la technologie car solide l'uranium iranien enrichi refroidissement à l'eau
En
Faute de questions c'est-à-dire de combattants on lève la séance
Bon et bien comme dans avec bones assemblée de copropriété
le procès-verbal vidéo est terminée et donc la semaine prochaine cette fois c'est eux